See this.
I'm pouring my coffee into a Joe Rogan experience mug.
I got the idea.
I stole it from Greg Fitzsimmons cause I have two,
not one but two Greg Fitz show the fits dog radio show cups at my house.
I'd gladly,
happily gloriously pour my coffee into these.
What's going on with the volume of these things?
Is it changed?
Is it,
yeah,
I think we're all definitely,
maybe that's what it is.
We shot a lot of guns yesterday due to due to this episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by ting.
What Ting is,
is a mobile service company that cuts out all the bullshit that you usually have
to deal with when you get cell phone service.
They have excellent coverage because they use sprints.
Backbone,
it sounds,
it's a weird word.
They need a better word than backbone.
Anyway,
they use the sprint network,
let's say that and so you get sprint coverage,
but you get to do it on tings terms,
which is far more ethical than you're going to get from any other cell phone per
weekend leave.
Yeah.
You can leave anytime you want to contract.
No contracts,
no early termination fees.
There's no,
you just,
you just leave,
you know and you just leave.
You don't,
you own the phone too.
He bought,
when you buy a phone from another provider,
like one of the big name ones,
most of the time you're not really buying the phone.
You're sort of leasing it.
Like if it says the phones to 99 with a contract,
what that means is it's two 99 but it's really 600 bucks.
So the,
the other 300 bucks you still owe.
So when you go to leave,
depending on,
say if you have a contract for three years and you only stay for a year,
you still owe two years of paying off that phone and that's what they hit you
with.
It's stupid.
It just doesn't make any sense.
It's dumb.
Accessible feature phone that your grandma has been asking for.
The Samsung.
Is it a flip phone?
Flip phone.
That's where Dave Gray.
Wow.
They still have flip phones.
Yeah.
Tell has one of those.
He knows the flip phone.
Dana white uses a flip phone.
He left.
Well,
he's really good with his thumb.
Like he could talk to you like and he'll text message people under the table
while he's like multitasking without anybody knowing about it because of the
buttons,
the actual buttons of the cell phone is what he likes.
So like I've,
I've had conversations with him under the table while he's in the middle of
talking about other shit.
He'll just be able to text you.
That's great.
Yeah.
It's because the,
you understand the thumb thing?
I don't think that's going on with David Tell.
I think he's just a fucking smash out though,
man.
As a feature phone.
It's battery life has counted in days,
not hours.
It almost makes me want to really see if I can just like take an iPad around and
use the money.
These little baby phones.
Well you certainly could do that.
You certainly could use a little flip phone and then do all your texting and
everything else on an iPhone.
Right?
Or Samsung it as your second phone.
Yeah,
because there's just,
my phone is not just my phone anymore.
It's,
there's too much connected calendars.
And let me check my email.
Let me see what this is
all,
let me put this on Instagram.
Holy Shit.
I gotta get a picture of this to have that more than one device.
But then again the best way to answer a phone,
it's star trek style really is open and the one you had done with someone,
you snap that bitch shut that.
Listen,
I'm not interested.
Thank you very much.
Shut that bitch.
Boom.
Because you can't slam an iPhone.
You can slam a flip phone cause slam that shit.
You feel good about yourself.
You can get one for 52 bucks,
the Sanyo 38,
10 red.
I would like to do a side by side comparison of phone sound quality and uh,
your uh,
your ability to get a signal to yeah,
that'd be interesting.
Anyway,
they,
they offer you a bunch of different options.
If you don't want one of those,
you can bring over an iPhone from sprint and you can also get some of these
really intensely cool android phones,
including the Lgg flax and see this thing,
it fucking curves.
Like your face.
They were just,
um,
demonstrating on television.
These new screens that are going to be completely flexible,
they're going to be able to curl.
So you're going to be able to have a phone that's a tube,
like a scroll,
and you're going to be able to pull that scroll open and you know,
I mean it could be a fucking foot long,
but then it rolls down to the size of a chapstick.
It's an amazing breakthrough.
What's the update on the malaria vaccine?
I know you're calling with something.
Look,
they're working at the two.
There's just not as much money.
People,
malaria tend to drain their backgrounds quite quickly.
You never get a call from a guy,
I got malaria,
I need hell.
It's like,
well,
no wonder we're not carrying this.
Got You.
Drop us a line.
Me,
mom,
malaria kills more people than uh,
well they had,
this does graph where they showed how many people were killed by mosquitoes and
how many people have been killed by war.
Mosquitoes is more than war.
Right.
Which is hard to wrap your fucking head.
I think it's more than family.
Yeah.
Pull it up.
Brian's.
See if you could find that thing.
It's the number one killer.
Yeah.
Malaria.
There's a chart,
a chart that shows how many,
uh,
what,
what kills humans most like it goes from,
um,
it goes from that to sharks to a bunch of other shit that kill people,
which are surprisingly small.
Spiders,
insects,
any types of Asian transportation.
That's pretty high these days.
There was a video there showing on the Internet the other day of a traffic and
in some African country where they don't have any,
uh,
any traffic lights at all,
and just people just going into intersections,
just freaking out and hitting the brakes and speeding up and crashing into each
other.
Find,
don't pull,
pull,
just pull up the fucking charts,
look for it.
Just find it will be all right here.
Malaria chart will be over here.
Brian will do everything is such an opportunity to see how much you're able to
let go.
Yeah.
You know,
because you can,
in La,
you,
if you don't develop that skill,
you're going to have to move.
I got in business guy in this giant fucking truck today that was going super
fast and I got in front of him and he hit his horn and I'm like,
come on man.
What you want everybody to wait behind you?
You're going fucking 10 miles now in this stupid big diesel truck pulling a ton
of shit.
He shouldn't be freaking out if someone doesn't want to be behind you.
Right.
It wasn't like I slowed him down for anything more than a half of a second.
Yeah.
People are just so weird about that.
Get in front of him at all.
But
yeah.
Ah Man,
I don't like to race.
And you cheated and it's,
it's a punishment.
The Horn is there so that you can prevent an accident from happening.
It's to warn somebody that something is happening.
They don't see,
it's not after the fact to punish them.
Yeah.
Or it's a twat alarm.
Occasionally you see people using the horn,
they're like,
oh look,
there's a Twat.
Ah Nah,
Nah,
Nah.
This reasons to use a horn like,
hey dickhead,
get out of the fucking road.
Right.
And look out man,
what are you doing?
But there was no look out today.
I was just getting in front of crazy slow truck that was going below the speed
limit.
Yeah,
that Shit's annoying.
You know you shouldn't do,
they shouldn't even be allowed.
Those big stupid trucks.
18 wheelers was a big truck.
I mean I don't know how many,
it was like some giant ass fucking diesel thing.
Yeah.
I don't know what they were.
I wasn't paying attention.
I was just like,
Oh fuck,
I'm behind.
This guy was one of those.
Yeah.
They should have special roads for those fucking things like on the highway.
That freaks me out man.
And train tracks.
That's where they should fucking ship stuff.
Just put it in more train tracks.
Well you get those guys all met up to try to stay awake so they can make long
trips and stay up for hours.
Fuck man.
Whenever I'm on the highway and I'm next to one of those things in my cube
together,
keep it together past this motherfucker,
go,
go.
It's just like a potential bomb.
Girlfriend of mine in high school get hit by one of those,
an 18 wheeler car.
Didn't even,
he didn't even fucking see the car.
He turned into her lane and clipped her and send her flying into a ditch and he
didn't even stop but shit died.
No,
no,
she lived.
She was okay.
But she freaked out.
She spun out car spun out,
but it's like this guy didn't even stop.
Fuck.
It keeps going.
I didn't see shit.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I mean those things are,
you think about how many hours they're logging did it can't be painted in the
hall.
Impossible.
And it's impossible.
You'd go mad,
you go mad if that was your job.
Just pay attention to the road over and over again and you start,
I would love to see,
well now I think the record,
all these guys inside their trucks and they do it for accidents,
for insurance purposes so they can find out.
But before they used to do that,
I bet guys would just go bananas and start singing crazy shit to them saying to
themselves,
screaming,
racist shit.
The top,
yeah.
Lungs while they're driving me.
I can't do that anymore.
There was a lot of,
show me your tits.
It's truck cause I think in the 70s that was like a thing.
There was a point where truckers were kind of seen as cool.
Like I remember smokey and the bandit [inaudible] there was a time where like
truckers were seen as like,
you know,
they had the caps and the mullet was cool back then and it was something new,
something kind of seedy,
cool.
Know this is all on camera.
You're doing all those we truck,
I can't find this malaria charity,
but there is this chart is this code that that
more than half of the 15 a thousand or 1500 uh,
malaria cases in 2007 we're in six areas and it's like New York,
California,
Texas,
malaria in California,
in La we had a big,
we had a big warning Adventist.
There were signs all over the trees to look at from malaria.
You know what?
There was just some foams,
Zo also fucking countries who come over here with the dirty fucking diseases and
they get stung by a bugs.
Bugs.
Let me tell you about bugs.
I bugs say day.
Got a fucking horn.
Get Out.
I'm going to stick the Santana up your fucking ass.
Give you this dirty malaria that I got from some country.
You can from a pronounce.
You got you.
Come over.
You come over here.
I'll take your women,
put them in a basement in New Jersey will [inaudible] that's only showing
America,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's not cool yet to go.
Africa seem like Maryland suspect being in this list though.
Like why New York?
California,
Texas.
Well listen,
I guarantee you most of those people have gotten it from somewhere else and then
flew back to America.
That's probably what happened.
I know it dude got malaria.
I knew a dude.
Justin Wren,
the guy who uh,
I guess we're still doing a tinker Marshall thing.
Dot Com.
Save 25 bucks off.
Awesome.
Yeah,
they have iPhone five for two 49.
Man,
that's crazy cheap.
Yeah,
that's pretty good things.
Awesome.
Um,
the thing that I love the most about things that the cut out all the bullshit.
You don't,
you don't have to deal with anything.
I think that's going to be the future too.
Like you don't pay if you go over a certain amount,
you know pay like a penalty.
You just pay for what you use all across the board.
So if you only use your phone for a bit,
you have a little bill.
You hope that's the future.
And I think TV should be the same way.
Just if I watch a TV show charged me a dime,
if I watch how I met your mother,
that's a fucking dime and movie a dollar,
whatever.
But it should be like a running bill based on what you watch.
The problem I have with that is that essentially what we're dealing with now is
the entrance of the Internet into the world of television,
slowly making its way onto the TV just with,
with Netflix and also with the different apps that you have on television now
that allows you to watch youtube videos.
I mean telephones come with TV's rather come with apps and I think that if we
start charging more for more content than it kind of fucks up the whole benefit
of the Internet.
Right.
The benefit of the Internet being net neutrality being the idea that everybody
should have equal access to the Internet.
And that's a big point of contention right now.
So because of the new cars,
the new Internet is going to eventually,
like the new television is going to be the internet.
It's not,
it's,
you're not going to be able to control with NBC,
CBS,
Fox.
The only reason why they'd be able to do it so far is because it's a long
tradition,
but the way they distribute things is antiquated.
It's stupid.
Like the only reason why you can't rewind and pause this is because it's
happening right now.
It's absolutely 100% live with no delay.
This podcast is,
there's very few things on television.
They're like that.
And so that because of that,
these guys are allowed to put things up when they want to and you have to sit
through the whole thing,
including they changed the recipe on how many commercials,
I mean he used to be,
they played in a 30 minute Sitcom.
It was 26 minutes of Sitcom.
Now it's down to like 21 it's crazy.
Yeah.
And it's just because they can make x amount more per year for that extra
minute.
rogan.ting.com save yourself some money.
That's it.
That's it for you to in commercial.
It's going an awesome company commercial too.
I feel like it's about as good as if I'm the person at Ting and there is
somebody in the office that actually has two.
They do things called air checks,
which I guess Brian,
you send those in.
I've gotten complaints about those.
We've lost clients because of the,
well,
I would imagine because you do the commercial,
you're away and I think that that's got to sell way more than somebody reading
it wrote off the page.
You imagine some people don't like it though.
There was some business oriented companies that thought they were going to
capitalize just based on numbers and you know,
we started talking about giant dicks and fucking Werewolf's and whatever.
It just took a turn.
This tink bitch covering up her delicious tits with this charity that's not,
she's,
oh,
she's a woman dudes.
Nice woman.
She looks like Meg Ryan.
She's looks like Meg Ryan.
If they photo shopped her waist to waist to hip ratio,
Meg Ryan and a prime man when she was something special.
She was odd.
Have she's it.
She's a nice lady who had a rough life in the spotlight over here.
Hanging out with iPhones.
Yeah.
Anyway,
rogan.ting.com we're also about to you on it.com that's o n n I t on it.
We sell a bunch of different cool shit,
including supplements,
strength and conditioning equipment,
protein powder made from the finest Canadian hemp.
It's illegal to buy hemp that's made and grown in California.
Greg,
did you know that?
I did know that.
That's illegal.
Crazy.
Can't grow hemp even though it does not even psychoactive.
You're not allowed to grow it because it knows marijuana because the marijuana,
the THC,
it's like its neighbor.
They call each other like no,
fuck face.
You're too close.
You're too close to that criminal.
It's like knowing a criminal keeps you out of an office.
It's like,
wow.
You know,
that's really what it is.
So what we've got to buy it from Canada.
We can't even grow it in America.
It's totally non cycle by some of that cause I gotta put it will help me put
some weight on.
I need to,
I need to bulk up a little bit.
Protein powder will certainly help.
The best thing for bulking up though is lifting heavy weights.
Standing me dating Brian will work.
If you get
Brian,
we'll get a diet and put it together for you.
Everything that he eats,
all the olive garden's specials,
but you'll get again the wrong way.
Lifting weights though,
um,
is you get,
if you're going to do a dump,
put stop.
I do sets of like eight.
I should be doing sets.
Don't laugh.
We're in the middle of a fucking commercial in the conversation.
Pay attention to what you're doing.
Or I'm doing sets of like five things.
It's help it,
right.
It should be a work with a trainer.
You find some dude,
some Brian's train and me and Brian Callen workout at the same gym and he's got
his trainer.
Got Somebody.
He's,
it's like a 20 minute workout,
but they don't stop.
It's hardcore for 20 minutes.
Well.
That's really a great idea to do it that way.
A lot of people,
that's one of the things they like kettle bells
is that it's so intensive.
You so much of your body that you could burn out a serious workout in 25
minutes.
Yeah,
like if I only have 15 minutes to to do something like and then I have to shower
and go.
I literally can get a workout in 15 minutes.
It's not ideal.
I like to work out for like a strong hour plus I like to have enough time,
but if I want to I could bang out a kettlebell workout in 15 minutes.
When you say an hour,
does that include cardio or that's all just lifting weights?
Friends?
Just depends on where I'm at.
If I'm at a gym,
like say if I'm staying at a hotel,
I'll lift weights and do cardio.
I lift weights first and then I'll do cardio.
Yeah,
always lift weights first.
Oh no shit.
I thought it was the opposite.
You'll get tired quicker.
You won't be able to put it in as much work with the weights.
I thought you wanted to get your heart going and some sweat gums.
Well,
I do do that,
but that they don't consider that cardio.
I do a 10 minute warmup,
right?
The 10 minute warmup,
usually on an elliptical machine,
it's just a,
I just do like these little intervals on an elliptical machine just to raise my
heart rate,
but it's not like real cardio.
So I do that and then I lift weights and then after lifting weights,
I feel like you can push the cardio when your muscles are sore,
but you can't really push your muscles when you cardio's dead,
you're just exhausted from a hard half an hour of sprinting on an elliptical
machine.
So then you go back on the elliptical after.
Yeah.
I love the elliptical.
What a great fucking work.
Fantastic for your body.
There's no trauma,
there's no banging around and no soreness of the joints and you know it's just,
and you can get a real fucking workout.
Brian,
stop focusing on people.
Just put up,
put up the pictures of us.
Yeah,
I'm going to get some of that powder and I'm going to go with some heavier
weights.
You're just focusing on chicks zooming in on this girl.
Zoom in on that girl every time.
No,
I just researched this website,
find things that I didn't know about.
Like I didn't know that@thecoveroftheon.com I didn't know that they have this
new thing which shows a bunch of videos.
That guy,
uh,
on it videos now that pops up like this thing scrolls left and right.
And that's how I accidentally hit that video of you talking like right here.
Like where are all cool?
It's all done in house to the,
uh,
all this stuff.
Does Dallas diamond page,
the guy in the upper left hand corner,
former pro wrestler.
He's a yoga advocate now.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I've seen that.
Has his own like style of yoga that was put together,
brings all these former pro wrestlers and helps them out with yoga.
Yeah,
they get a piece on him on a,
I think HBS sports are one of those shows and it's like very,
a lot of them,
uh,
had addictions to a um,
barbiturates and a lot of them were drunks and,
and a big part of it is recovery too.
They get sober as they did
huge part of it.
The Dallas time and page,
he brings in all those guys that used to be pro wrestlers or even current guys
that are injured and fucked up.
And a lot of those guys,
they turn to pills.
Pain pills are a big problem in a lot of athletes cause you're,
you know,
football players have problem with them.
I knew this baseball guy who has his career fell apart because of pills or hurt
himself,
got a little surgery on something and they got him on pain pills to recover from
the surgery and then boom,
he's off to the races.
He just often doesn't take long.
No,
no.
There's,
and especially if you have the,
you know,
there's certain
people that just,
for whatever reason,
they seem to get addicted quicker.
Well,
you know,
I quit drinking 24 years ago when I first met you were,
you were sober,
right?
Right.
When we first met,
I had just gotten sober
and then I had shoulder surgery about five years ago and they gave me,
um,
you know,
Vicodin and all that year,
year and a half later still pop in that shit.
I had
prescriptions going with three different doctors and then I went off of it.
It was a dark time going off that shit.
Yeah,
on a.com.
Oh.
And I said,
fuck the music.
It's just,
just turn the show on.
We talked,
we were to,
this is too free form to have a,
an actual opening.
I think I'm going to kill the opening.
I think I'm going to add it in post because the opening line,
if fucking weirds everything out,
it's like all of a sudden music plays and you have to start from scratch.
It's like you kill the momentum.
So how are you going to do it?
Just like this.
No,
but I mean,
uh,
how did you use to do it?
Like you used to like stop cue the music and then Joe Rogan.
Right,
right,
right.
But like why would,
why are we doing that?
Because it kind of feels like a start.
I think.
I know it does.
You know what it also does though?
It kills the momentum of the conversation.
That's why I don't do it sometimes because I feel like we'd get this groove
going.
All right.
Why?
Because in the future you might not like Ting.
You'd be like,
fuck,
taking the off and then you want to just be able to cut,
like cut it off too.
Don't even say that rude.
No,
no,
no.
But someone asked me if I wanted to put together a best of the fleshlight
commercials.
I'm like,
that seems like that would be kind of advertising,
you know,
like that doesn't seem like a smart move because we don't use them anymore in
the Promo code probably doesn't work anymore.
Okay.
Funniest.
Fuck.
Maybe some of them were hilarious.
Yeah.
Some of them who are Larry,
maybe if a fleshlight wants to get involved,
we want a piece of the action.
Bring it back just for just for some videos.
Um,
but uh,
so these doctors didn't know about each other when you have three different
prescriptions,
obviously that's what's crazy states or same state,
you know.
No,
all in the same state.
One was my general practitioner when was the guy who was,
um,
who had done the operation and then the other one was the PT guy.
And so,
and then,
you know,
you start,
you start looking for pills
where,
God damn,
dude.
Yeah.
I knew a guy who did that with oxies.
He got a backside.
Yeah.
That's,
that's hardcore.
And he just,
he had a one in Texas.
He had one down here and different doctors feeding the pills.
And you still couldn't,
couldn't keep them in the system,
just shoving them in.
It's,
it's heroin.
Oxy,
I mean,
it's the same exact chemical makeup.
Yeah.
And just like you were saying,
he went dark,
you know,
it was dark time.
We could still,
like there's a cloud walking over him.
When did see him?
Yeah,
like a,
those snoopy cartoons.
Right.
The one dude was a cloud.
Right,
right.
It was literally like that.
Yeah.
Poor guy.
It's um,
it's tough because
you feel great.
I'm not going to lie to you when you are on those pills,
you can talk to like at some ass all you run into a comedy club that you would
normally avoid.
I can engage.
I can have a long conversation.
I was doing an hour and 40 minutes sets where I was just free form and I could
sit and write scripts.
I mean it was just for whatever my chemical makeup is that's fucked up.
It righted it on the heroin.
Yeah.
Bag on him.
All the Greg Vicodins isn't heroin though,
right?
Vikings is a
lighter version of it.
Everyone's not that bad.
If you just don't take a bath,
you're fine if you don't take a bath.
Yeah.
When you're on heroin because they wanted guys.
Right,
right.
Well,
the problem with it is that you're,
you're um,
uh,
perceptives your,
what's the happiness,
uh,
chemical in you?
A dopamine.
Serotonin.
Yeah.
Your serotonin receptors get clogged up by the chemicals in barbiturates so you
no longer are able to receive um,
serotonin because those are the only thing that is,
that is making you feel good is the drug.
And then you have to,
when you go off it,
it takes a while for those receptors to clean out and be able to accept
serotonin again.
And that's where you get really dark.
That's,
yeah,
that's a,
a friend had the same issue coming off.
Coke was that same thing,
just depleted receptors.
It just hyper taxes your system.
That's the big deal with coming off ecstasy,
right?
That's where people started getting into five HTP.
They started getting into five HTP because people were coming off of ecstasy and
the serotonin would you be depleted?
And then they realize if you take five HTP while you're tripping before you
tripping,
like while you're tripping,
after you're tripping,
it gives your brain the building blocks to rebuild Serotonin,
coworker,
right?
Everything you are as a human being.
This is the,
this is the thing that people have a hard time wrapping their heads around when
it comes to like their diet or when it comes to their,
uh,
you know,
how,
how much nutrients they take in your body.
Your body is literally built on food.
It's built on food.
That's the only way it gets built.
You have to give it fuel.
The fuel that you give,
it depends.
It depends entirely on the nutritional properties of that fuel to give your body
enough to build,
rebuild itself.
And in certain circumstances,
what you're doing to your body just depletes its reserves of anything like where
the Serotonin,
whether it's dopamine,
when you know,
that's the thing that happens to guys when they're on steroids,
they get off steroids or testicles don't work anymore.
It's,
you get testicular atrophy.
Same thing.
You just deplete your body's ability to do something.
Just wreck the whole,
even if you just dial,
you see some people fuck it,
Starbucks and they got the sugar and they just turn it upside down and you
literally,
you think,
okay,
that's crazy amount.
And then they keep going and,
and you realize like I did a cleanse a couple times because basically your
system needs once in awhile to not have to deal with all this shit and just
drain it all out so that it can relax.
You know,
it's like turning off your computer so your hard drive and go to sleep for a
little while and if you don't do that,
you're just,
you're
fighting all that
time.
Yeah.
When you introduce something to it,
like if I get in or heroin users,
you're upsetting your system in such a crazy way to your,
your system doesn't know what the fuck's going on.
Right.
It's like every now and then this guy takes this stuff in and we're on this wild
ride and then our reserves are depleted and we have to scramble to get that wild
ride again.
Otherwise we're not going to be even right.
Like that's one of the saddest things.
Everyone,
you see those pill guys that they only take the pills to get,
even when they're not on the pills,
they're sick.
They get that sickness that they just can't deal with and they take the pills to
just relax a little.
Yeah,
I know.
Well what,
what's your feeling?
I like raw food.
That seems to be what people do now.
Some raw food is really good for you.
Some foods are better when they're cooked.
Yeah.
Um,
there's,
we had,
Steve Maxwell's is a famous strength and conditioning and nutrition health guy
who was worked with a lot of MMA fighters and he's just a really knowledgeable
guy always on top of like health and wellness type stuff.
And he was talking about the cellulose in like Broccoli and certain vegetables.
Like your body doesn't even process it correctly unless its cell walls.
You have to cook it in order to get the most out of it to make it the most
nutritious.
Which I thought was really interesting because a lot of people think that most
vegetables,
like eating most vegetables raw like raw vegetables is like the way to go,
which I think it is.
You know what I think?
I think there's no correct answer.
There's like some things are better raw,
some things are better cooked.
Some you probably should have both.
You probably should have animal protein as well as vegetable protein.
Like I always make fun of Vegans,
but if you saw what I eat on the most part,
I eat a shit ton of vegetables and I eat vegetables all day long.
I think it's the most important thing other than like a good quality source of
protein that you're taking your body.
I feel different when I eat a lot of like green leafy,
Oh hell yeah.
I feel different if not better.
Right.
And I also,
um,
I,
I fart a lot if I eat vegetables,
a lot of fruit,
a lot.
I fought,
I fought to the point where I got a hemorrhoid and I get this hemorrhoid and I
can't get rid of it.
And I noticed that like,
I fart probably,
you know,
when I'm really gone,
I probably far 20 times a day and they're long,
far.
And it's hard.
If I'm traveling,
I get off the plane,
I'm cramped up because I won't fight in the plane.
Oh,
you're a sweetie cross country.
So I go to the urinal and I,
I was just my son one time,
we were coming back from a trip from Florida and we went into the men's room and
we're both of the urinal and that's where I let it rip.
And I mean,
it's like a crazy comedy farce.
And he started laughing so hard.
He's face turned red and he left.
He's like,
yeah,
man,
I can't believe you did that.
I go,
that's what a gentleman does.
That meant I didn't do that on the plate,
dude.
Good for you.
Right.
Do you take enzymes?
I just got some,
uh,
probiotics in the mail.
I'm going to start taking.
That's different than maybe what that is.
Yeah.
I mean,
probiotics are very good.
It's very good for intestinal health and the uh,
digestive health.
But a man enzymes really important as well.
Yeah,
you can buy enzymes like so.
Lots of good one.
I'll get you some,
I'll get you some on at once.
The,
um,
there's,
there's a ton of good ones that are on the market.
There's a,
there are certain enzymes that are in certain vegetables and certain fruits,
especially like Papaya.
Papaya is a big one for digestion.
Yeah.
That's why you ever eat at one of those Brazilian places,
those Fogo de Chao places.
Yeah,
they're awesome.
But one of the best desserts they have is this Papaya smoothies.
Right,
right.
And one of the cool things about it is the Papaya actually has,
I think it's Pectin or one of those,
some enzyme that helps you digest all the meat.
So it's like a good post meal thing.
It's beautiful and it's tastes so fucking good.
That's where the fighting comes from,
they say is because the fruit and the meat together.
Yeah.
Break down at different times so that fruit digests immediately.
So it forms a bubble behind the big red meat.
And then as you,
as you digest the red meat,
it releases the Papaya Fart.
Oh yeah.
It's intense.
Well they say that if you're gonna eat like one of the best way they,
I don't know who they are,
but the people who I've talked to that are health and nutrition Democrats say
that you should have,
um,
like your vegetables should be like one of the first things you eat,
like eating a vegetable smoothie and you are eating a fruit smoothie.
Sometimes fruit or vegetable based is like one of the most important things
early cause it kind of like opens the pipes up and lubes him down that way when
you're eating something else,
if you eat something that's a meat based meal later,
like to attacking,
you're already open and you know,
you already sent in the troops to clear out the fucking forest and then you shit
comes flying out of you.
So there's a logic to like the Italian six course meal versus the Antipasto with
just some raw vegetables and a,
and then that loosens it up.
And then you get the heavy carb pasta as your second meal because then,
then you,
uh,
I never followed because I'm so fucking stuff.
I'm Irish.
So the first,
the first,
you know,
wave comes and we just attack it.
Like there's never going to be food again.
And then they keep bringing,
like I,
my friend Frank Moretti's Italian,
we used to,
I used to have dinner at his house and they had fucking anti pasta,
then pasta,
then they'd have shrimped and they'd have like a,
uh,
another post,
then a meat.
And I was just,
I felt embarrassed that I couldn't keep eating because I eat and too much.
Well,
you know what,
that's an important point when it comes to eating,
that it's not just about health.
Like I think you should eat for health sake most of the time because I think
your body of work better and you'll feel better.
But that said,
you should also enjoy food like as a delicious art form.
Yeah.
And like if you go to a really jam and Italian restaurant and they bring out a
five course meal and it's got anti pasta,
delicious Lasagna,
and then there's a me causing like,
oh my God,
like you're a wash in like a,
an an orgy of sensation.
Right,
right.
And you should appreciate that for what it is like,
yeah,
you're going to be sleepy afterwards.
Yeah.
It's not the best thing for you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But every now and again,
it's a great to do.
Let's do
it.
Me,
you and Collin and our wives.
Let's go to a good fucking restaurant.
Okay,
let's do it.
Come on.
What did I get too excited?
I'm ready.
You got me excited.
No serious.
I was thinking about that the other day.
They were due.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
I'm down 100%.
Let's do a count is going to be here right after you.
So we'll,
we'll work it out.
Right?
Here's the answer when you were asking earlier the difference between heroin and
Vicodin.
Um,
so heroin,
it's a,
according to this post,
online has a,
a greater euphoric and analgesic property than Vicodin.
It's a less potent and an oral to a milligram basis.
So heroin is indistinguishable from morphine if administered any way other than
Ivy.
And heroin is more sedating than hydrocodone by a very notable degree.
So it seems that heroin slows you down more.
It's more of a sedative not out.
That's probably like when you taking Viking and you felt like really creative
and you've got a lot done.
I think that the Vicodin,
uh,
it quells your fears and your anxieties seems to be an extreme antianxiety pill.
No shit cause creativity.
Once you feel anxious,
it tightens up.
You lose it sometimes it didn't hanses it with me though.
Yeah.
Sometimes like when I,
uh,
especially pot,
like eating pot for me,
there's a,
there's oftentimes a period of anxiety or a feeling of vulnerability.
Just a real,
just a reality of being a person,
being a,
a finite life form.
Good,
weird man.
You just weird out,
you know?
But then afterwards I have,
I sort of relax from that and then I have this wave of ideas.
It comes,
it's just like a gift for tolerating all the freak out.
It's like the universal,
okay,
you got through that good.
Here's some ideas.
Whew.
These are like gifts,
like gifts from the Gods,
you know?
Right.
But I don't get that from Viking.
Then I only took viking in once and it didn't work with me with my,
with my system.
It just made me a moron.
I was just sitting on,
maybe I was too much.
Maybe I overdosed or something.
Second.
Right here.
If you guys want to take some and try it out.
You have vitamins on you?
Yeah.
Why do you Vika then Dayaks had been in this box for like the last year when I
had my operation.
My teeth.
Yeah.
I don't like Viking in so I just kept it here.
Keep Viking.
How am I gonna explain it to cops and I'm like,
I don't know where the bike thing came from.
I don't even have like in,
and that's not,
did you plant Viking and then accused the Capa Planning Vika then wait,
so you shoots my dog
eat dog.
That's what they do.
They shoot dodge and you haven't seen the fucking videos of cops shooting dog.
There's so many cops that actually enjoy shooting dogs.
These are like collies bark when they come to arrest someone for something and
they just unload on the dog.
Yeah.
It's a fear tactic and it's also to let them know that,
you know,
I'm completely in control here.
I just shot your dog.
You're in shock now.
And it's a tactic of control and manipulation.
Control.
It happens all the time.
Clock cop allegedly back a smile after fatally shooting friendly,
dark.
They do it all the time.
Yeah.
Do it all the time.
Yeah,
there was,
there was a,
I mean there's a ton of videos I hate even talking about because it makes me
sick.
There's a ton of videos online cops,
they're just fucking shooting dogs.
Huh?
You know,
I get it.
If you were going over a bad guy's house and that bad guy has some dogs and
those dogs would sick you,
I get it.
But there's a lot of times when they're doing it with,
that's not the case at all.
There was a guy who was a fucking mayor and um,
they,
uh,
they shot his dog and they shot,
um,
another dog ran away and hid and they chased after the dog.
And while I was hiding,
they shot that they were shit labs,
chocolate labs.
And then I think their chocolate,
maybe golden labs,
but I remember them being like really like dogs you never have to worry about.
And then,
um,
they,
uh,
arrest the family because someone had delivered some marijuana to the wrong
address.
So what it was probably was that this guy was a postman and the postman was
working some sort of a drug deal.
And what he would do is he would,
he would be delivering to a certain address.
So instead of him actually delivering the package,
the package was going to that address.
He handles all the packages that go to that address.
Instead of that,
he picked up the package himself and it was pot.
So the,
the people that were in the house where it turned out to actually be a mayor.
So they,
this guy was fucking,
haven't pot delivered to this mayor's house.
So this guy,
uh,
you know,
the mayor had nothing to do with it.
So they break down his house,
they break down his door,
shoot his dog chases other dog and hiding shooted fucking zip tie.
Everybody treat him like they're drug dealers.
And then it turns out black,
I believe.
I don't remember.
Okay,
let's find this sounds familiar.
Yes.
I think he was mayor.
I want,
I don't want to fucking,
I want to say of DC
now.
I remember it was around DC.
It might've been a little bit south at the dog owners.
Black.
It's way more scary than if a white dog owner,
right?
No.
And then the,
um,
it got big.
I think Obama climate did on it.
What do you mean?
Right?
Like if,
if,
if it's probably like if you go to somebody's house and a bunch of dogs,
or like at the door,
you're probably more scared and a black guy's house in the white guy's house.
Why?
Because white guys have like shit like bitch dogs usually.
I think that's a fair,
that's a fair stereotype.
I mean,
there is a bitch if you're in,
if you're in the hood,
there is a fair,
there's a fair chance that those dogs have been bred to fight or at least be
very aggressive.
Okay.
It's,
it is.
It's Maryland.
And here's the,
um,
it's Berwyn heights.
And here's the actual story from Wikipedia.
The Berwyn heights mayors,
residents.
Drug raid was a controversial,
controversial action taken by the Prince George County,
Maryland Sheriff's office and Police Department at the home of Berwyn Heights,
mayor,
uh,
Shay,
c.
H.
E.
Y.
Calvo.
I Dunno how to say that.
In 2008 the raid was a culmination of investigation would that began in Arizona
where a package containing 32 pounds of was intercepted at a warehouse address
to the mayor's residents.
In spite of intercepting the package in transit,
the police allowed to package to be delivered and once the package arrived,
the house,
a swat team raided and held the mayor in his mother in law at gunpoint,
shot and killed his two dogs,
one while at attempted to run away the event gained national and international
media attention.
Why Calvos?
While the Calvin [inaudible],
I guess,
were cleared of wrongdoing,
the police were accused by the Calvos and civil rights groups of lacking a
proper search warrant,
excessive force and failure to conduct a proper background investigation of the
home being raided.
Yeah,
I think,
I think Obama made a statement about it.
As a matter of fact,
in 2010 and August,
the sheriff say stated we'd do it again tonight.
Alright,
I love cops.
Sorry.
Stays do it again tonight.
He said,
Omar drawn that Sheriff Gel and,
and uh,
Phoenix.
He us,
it's like,
I don't know what the checks and balances is on sheriffs,
but they seem to be able to say whatever the fuck they want.
There's some Douche bags out there.
The sheriff's,
that's for sure.
I mean like everything.
There's,
there's cops that are great and then this cops that are,
that suck at it,
right?
And it's fucking really hard job.
That's part of the problem.
They don't get enough respect.
It's a really hard job.
It's a super dangerous job at developed,
well paid.
It's not well paid.
And they developed this us versus them mentality,
which is super dangerous because they are us.
This idea that you're not us,
that you can go over a guy's house and shoot his fucking Labrador.
Yeah,
that's crazy man.
I mean it should be crazy,
but you get so used to the stress of combat a daily basis.
Imagine being a fucking cop.
Everybody you deal with all day is long to you.
Yeah.
My buddy's a cop in the South Bronx and he works the graveyard shift and he said
that they show up,
they'll show up to help somebody and people on rooftops in the tenements.
We'll start throwing fucking paint cans down on the street and just anytime they
see a uniform there,
it's like if we come into a place,
we need to make the arrest and get out of there in less than five minutes.
Otherwise a crowd gathers and it's like a near riot situation.
If you go into certain tenements,
imagine living like that,
you know,
you got to go and you're going in there because you know you're assisting the
fire department because somebody had a heart attack.
Or are you going and because there was reported domestic violence,
you're trying to help the community and you are under attack.
It's like fucking Iraq.
Well,
do you remember what happened during the La Riots?
Um,
after the Oj Simpson trial where they were shooting firefighters,
they're showing us,
wow.
They were shooting at people.
They're shooting at anybody with a union or the uniform.
And just white people in general.
I mean that whole Reginald Denny thing where they pulled him out of his truck
and bashed out a fucking brick off of his head on national television.
Do you remember that?
So,
yeah.
Unbelievably scary.
And you watch the fact that this guy for no reason other than the fact that the
guy was white,
pulls him out of a truck and then takes a brick and hurls it at his head.
Full clip.
Caving is facing right now that that happened just because the guy was white.
Right.
And the same thing with lynchings of black people in the south,
but what's really fucked.
Yeah,
but for sure.
But that was a different time.
You know,
it's really fuck that.
Like that kind of racism like the black against white racism.
White people go,
well yeah,
well we kind of have a common a little bit,
you know what I mean?
It was amazing.
He took lunch for the team.
All this fucking,
let's think about this owner of this basketball teams.
Donald's done.
All he said was keep hiding away from black people.
Don't take pictures of the black paper.
And everybody wants his head.
It's over.
He said,
come.
I mean,
look,
I'm not gonna obviously.
Do I even need to say we're not condoning it?
Of course we're not.
Of course,
but this dude has $1 billion team.
He has to fucking sell because he made some stupid states.
He didn't prohibit a black person from coming on the team.
He didn't mistreat a black person even he just made statements.
Yeah.
He apparently had a reputation for a long time of being racist,
and he was the guy that ran our test didn't eat,
was it Ron Artest and suit him in 2009 yeah.
Sued them for racial discrimination.
So it's obvious that the guy was a racist,
does no question.
We'll also,
he owns buildings and there was a,
there were lawsuits brought against him because he was profiling people into his
apartment.
He wasn't allowing black people and he lost millions of dollars in that,
in those lawsuits.
Right.
He's obviously a piece of shit.
There's no question.
No doubt.
He's a piece of shit.
However,
what did he say that was so awful,
but finding them $2 million.
He didn't use the n word.
No.
He said don't take pictures around black people because it makes me look bad.
He said,
you can fuck them.
That was what's even crazier and open minded guy.
You know what it was?
This is what happened,
man.
The chick was getting sued.
I don't know if you know this as white side.
The the wife was suing the side piece,
which is preposterous.
The white,
I mean she was humiliating her husband.
That's why she did it.
Yes,
but the idea was ridiculous.
The idea that you,
you can't take gifts back.
The guy gave away some gifts and he got the pussy.
You can give the pussy back.
Like what kind of ridiculous statement is that?
I mean it's,
the whole thing's ridiculous.
We were with prostitution was nice and legal.
That relationship could have existed in harmony for a long time.
If it was just above board out in the open.
I mean he gave her two Bentleys,
a Ferrari and a range rover,
Osha and he bought her this fat fucking crib.
It's just prostitution.
It's fun.
It should be fine.
And that kind of prostitution prefer girls like the perfect time.
You get like a relationship with the guy.
You don't have to fuck anybody else for money.
This guy gives you a ton of cash and if that's what you want to even say it,
he can go fuck other guys.
I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
I really don't.
Just like,
I don't think there's anything wrong with someone cleaning your teeth.
Is there?
I think some of wants to clean your fucking,
especially a chick
has been taken.
How thick ones from a basketball team.
Owners she,
she needs her teeth cleaned.
There's sticky and gummed up.
He's probably got like tar that comes out of
cigarettes.
Tar Spider webs.
Cigarettes are spiderwebs come out of his mouth when he comes up like cobwebs,
like fogged cobwebs,
sticking her hair.
He wraps his ball sack around her neck three times.
Go fucking TMZ has a thing that like,
he was out last night eating at a restaurant.
They were like the balls on this guy,
but,
but can you imagine how many like eating at a restaurant now people are probably
putting their pubic hairs in this places.
Yeah,
he's fucked.
And here's my take on the whole thing with like the,
the money thing,
like two point $5 million ain't shit to that dude.
He's 80 years old and he's got 1.9 billion for folks who don't know what a
billion is,
it's a thousand million.
So he has one point 9,000 million dollars.
You can take 2.5 million.
He's not going to notice he has too much money.
That's 0.02% of his money and the interest he's making on all this money.
Like he'll make that back in a week.
Their money comes and goes.
It's like,
it's like finding a guy like you 100 bucks,
right?
It's like you're not going to notice a hundred bucks.
It's going to be there.
It's gone.
He doesn't give a fuck.
But the public humiliation must be unbearable,
but a way to finish at your life.
You picture him even in his own country club that's filled with these reptilian
blue bloods.
Even those people are going to reject tagged with good.
But she said
she was out of line [inaudible] cut action dot on that stand out the world of
the billionaire Ferrari buyer.
I believe they live forever.
You know it's,
I went to the girl's Instagram too and it's like so many people are so fucking
mean.
It's there's something,
it's a weird thing we've got in our culture today where people could just
comment on videos and comment on pictures because there's folks out there that
are just waiting for someone that they can yell at.
Yup.
They don't have any connection to this woman like me.
I am.
I was curious about the whole thing.
I feel bad for the woman that she's that woman that has to sleep with this 80
year old man.
I feel bad for him that he's an old racist.
I feel bad for the whole situation.
So I life,
I feel bad for everybody.
So I'm looking at it just out of a public curiosity because here's a store that
I can't escape.
It's all over my Twitter feed.
But when I go to the Instagram and I see the comments like the other people's
reaction to this scenario,
that doesn't involve them in the slightest.
You fucking ugly pig whore,
you know,
get some more plastic surgery.
You can't,
you rat you piece of shit.
You know you did the right thing,
girl.
Fuck him.
You should have cut his dick off.
I mean,
you're just,
you're just reading fucked up.
Comment after fucked up coming.
Right?
What kind of a world is this where people think that's okay to do,
right?
Like they have pictures of their dog,
they have pictures of them on a hike,
they have pictures of their new car that they're washing.
Then they have a fucking comment on someone else's page.
You fucking cunt,
right?
Big Cuts your tits off.
You fuck with the wrong guy?
He's got $1 billion,
you know,
just the meanest shit,
right?
Right.
Well,
and like remember Monica Lewinsky?
Oh boy.
Did they fucking hate her?
But here's the thing,
this chick mark my words.
In one year she will have a reality show.
She will have an pocket book line.
She will be worth $1 billion.
Well,
in that sense it's good,
but it's in,
in another sense it's bad because they enter the world of hate.
It's like you remember when Kelsey Grammer's wife was on that real real
housewives of Beverly Hills and then they broke up and you know,
and then she became famous for being like a mean person on the show.
But they was so overwhelming.
But this wave of hate that came at her and she just,
she up to words that at first,
I don't think she knew what she was dealing.
I don't think she knew what she was getting into and I thought she was going to
try to be controversial.
You know,
apparently she's a nice person.
I know someone who's met her,
she's a nice person.
So she was trying to be controversial and do that show.
She's was
Dang as you think about like Andy Kaufman,
when he'd go into the ring and he'd fight fight women and he called it the
southerners rednecks in the own.
Like he was courting it and it was taken the right way.
I mean,
some people hate it and some people got it.
But nowadays people,
people go into it and they say,
I'm going to be a fucking pariah.
Yeah,
I'm going to represent everything people hate and I'm gonna make a lot of money
from it.
And they just figured out a way to rationalize it because of the fact that
they're,
you know,
they're going to get paid for it,
but you're also going to get paid back.
You have to realize you what you put out,
the way you make people feel,
that's exactly how they shoot back at Ya.
Right.
And there's some people that take it for no reason.
And then you know,
you see a girl and she's just beautiful and you know,
you hate her because you could never be here.
Or I hate her because you can never fucked her.
You know,
this,
this.
There's always going to be people that are just really negative for no reason.
But what do you think of the Kardashians?
So same thing.
I mean,
look the,
the haint that those,
those girls get,
look,
I mean,
do they deserve hate?
What do they do?
That's so horrible.
They do.
They don't do anything that's great.
They're doing don't do anything that's in traded and represent the worst thing
in America.
Not the worst thing in America.
It's not even close.
It's just shallowness.
The worst thing is violence.
The worst thing is rape.
The worst thing is people victimizing people bullying people in school,
bullying in the workplace.
That's the worst thing is meanness is,
is people just being violent,
hurting people.
What they're doing,
it's just being idiots that are shallow,
that run around,
and they broadcast them in front of you with really clever editing,
so you can't take your eyes away from it.
You find yourself watching it for no fucking reason.
Yeah,
the they're really evil is the reaction to it.
I mean,
kids are watching a shit.
They don't know that she got her start by doing a internet porn.
They just think that she's,
oh,
they fucking know.
Everybody knew everybody.
My kids know that she's famous because of that.
Your kids know.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Hold your kids.
You should 16 right now.
10 and 1310 13 sorry.
13 though.
They fucking know by the time they're eight,
they're yeah.
Blow jobs when they're like seven.
One kid tells another kid that his brother got his dick sucked and like what?
Someone's drinking pee.
No,
no,
no.
There's no drinking pee.
It feels good.
Why don't you like what?
And then they cover their dicks and then they sit around the school year.
They tell each other's things.
I was 11 when I heard about a blow job and,
and I remember thinking like,
I literally thought you blew on it.
Yes.
I thought so too.
I thought the exact same.
That's so funny.
I thought the exact same thing and it just,
it seems crazy and outlook.
People say,
well,
it's so gross girls,
they're giving blow jobs left and right in school and I think good.
It's better than getting pregnant.
Let him suck away.
No one's getting hurt with that.
This is not too wrong with it.
You know,
I had this conversation with some parents are the day this guy was his daughter.
Um,
you know,
you got a picture off her phone of her cuddling with her boyfriend,
but she's like 16,
the boyfriend's like 16 too.
And he's like,
you know,
who knows what else is going on.
He's all upset,
shaking his head.
And then the wife was like,
you know,
talking about how when she was 60,
it was actually another,
another mom's was,
was talking about how it was,
I know what I was like when I was 16 and I was like,
come on,
listen boys like girls and girls like boys were being crazy.
We're like,
we're attaching all the same sentiments that the puritans had and our parents
had and their parents had all these that we know to be silly now.
And all this suppression of natural sexuality is what makes people so fucked up
in the first place.
Right?
Any of my friends,
they have a daughter and when she was like 16,
17 years old,
she had a boyfriend.
And at first I was like,
I couldn't believe it.
They were letting the boyfriend sleep over,
you know,
knowing they were having sex.
And I thought,
God,
that's fucking twisted.
But then I thought I was having sex at that age,
but I was in a car.
Cops could come.
The whole aura of it was negative and shameful.
Why not let your kid feel that sex is a normal,
healthy thing.
And if you're doing it responsibly,
then why not?
Having a
boyfriend is no different than having a friend.
I think you make it.
Hence if you make it different,
that's certainly intense that way.
But if you make it different than it becomes different.
If you make it like,
oh forbidden,
you add to attach.
There's this girl that I dated in high school and me and her sister didn't get
along.
Her sister was just fucking angry and I was probably angry too.
And uh,
we uh,
for whatever reason we clashed.
And part of the reason was her sister was really hot.
Like,
um,
the,
the one who wasn't so hot was always angry and the hot one,
like dudes were just bombing on her left and right.
And uh,
that we in the,
the not so hot one got an argument at school.
And because of that,
like the,
the sister was not supposed to date me.
There was like this thing.
So because we weren't supposed to date each other,
it was like this law,
this romance that could be,
you know,
put together.
It's like the tension,
like we were meant to be together,
you know,
yet.
And then you're all parents finally let me date her somewhere along the line.
And I was like,
oh,
this is boring.
Stupid lasts like a month because I run,
me and Juliette killed himself.
Good.
As it gets,
they realize this is as good as it gets.
Yeah.
I mean,
the real problem that we have is with,
um,
the tension between males and females.
That's the real problem.
The anger that men have towards women and the anger that some women have towards
men.
It's so dangerous.
I think it's changing.
I really do.
I think that,
you know,
if you've been to Canada or Europe,
that they,
they,
that feeling between the genders is very different.
They're much more like friends over there.
And I added a specialist.
Yeah.
And I'm starting to see,
you know,
like my,
like talking about my friend's daughter,
like getting to know kids of that generation.
It's very different.
They really do hang out as a group more than the men and women are on,
on more of a,
even playing like my,
my son just had his first girlfriend and it was very chill.
It was like,
it wasn't,
he told us about it,
you know,
and they weren't,
it wasn't like a big high stakes adventure.
It was just like,
yeah,
we hang out,
we have lunch together,
you know,
as a group we go to movies,
whatever.
And he didn't fit.
He felt like he was getting serious.
So we broke up with her 13 he's like,
he even said,
he goes,
I'm 13 that's hilarious.
Done a great job.
We put a lot of like artificial charged,
the things that don't,
that don't have to be there.
You know,
this,
this artificial and like significance
I think a lot of is I'm watching TV shows and movies were,
romance is always the fucking central thing.
Every song that comes up.
It used to be people wrote songs about shit.
You know,
Hendrix would write about,
you know,
purple fucking,
Hayes and weird shit and now everything is about loving a girl or breaking up
with a girl.
Well those are the songs that resonate with people.
How many people connect relationships to a song?
There's a song that I listened to that all I can think of is driving to this
girl's house in the middle of the night.
There's a song radar love golden earring song.
If I hear that song is this,
my girlfriend in high school moved across the state and I'd go visit her.
Like we'd have a phone conversation like 10 o'clock at night.
She lived like a couple of hours away at 10 o'clock in the night.
I'd get in my car and drive to visit her and then listen to that song radar
love,
you know,
and like,
so that song to this day I hear it.
I think about that one person.
Right.
This is always like weird.
Yeah.
That's a great fucking tune man.
80 songs I fuck man.
I,
I think
that's an 80 song radar.
Love the 90s.
I think it's earlier than that.
I think it was like a 70 song.
Let's see.
Golden earring,
radar love.
Let's see.
Golden earring had like three monster songs.
Yeah.
And that was it.
But um,
no I had,
I bought a 76 Volkswagen rabbit and my 23,
he was 73.
Wow.
Play at Brian and when I was in red,
I love on you.
I can remember every fucking song.
I got this and I started driving
a school my senior year because my school was about 20 minutes away and uh,
every song burning down the house,
like I can name the 20 top songs were on the radio.
Then every one of them I still will listen to when it comes on today.
Just brings me back.
Yeah,
there are songs you just,
you just instantly remember where you were.
I was in my car in Boston and it was April and I was listening to Prince Song.
Sometimes it snows in April and I remember,
wow,
this is,
I've got to get out of fucking Boston.
Ah,
snow in April.
This signal,
right?
Michigan or Minnesota where a prince live.
That's just as ridiculous.
Sometimes it snows in April.
We'll fucking move cause that's crazy.
That's spraying bitch.
I know.
And kids go to college there.
People go like,
I'm going to go to Minnesota to go to college for four.
He's like,
did you fucking visit in the spring?
You really should've gone around January and checked it out.
You know you can go to Arizona State,
right?
It gets 50 yeah.
A real cold spell rolls in the town.
I mean Shit,
we went to college in Boston.
I don't know what the fuck,
but that's about in mind that I guess I was drunk the whole time.
Bother me that much.
Well,
the town is so great.
It almost makes up for the fight.
It's fucking cold as Dick in the winter.
Not when you're going to university Wisconsin.
Man.
There's no reason to be there unless you're really in Wisconsin type chicks.
Chicks who could make their own cheese.
Girls know how to farm and Fart in the farting Wisconsin girls probably that's
why they were skirts and a winner.
I live
in Boston,
so I went to school in Boston,
but I don't know if I would've stayed.
I Dunno.
I mean I,
if,
if I had an option to go somewhere else to go to school,
I probably wouldn't have went somewhere else.
I was attracted because of the history of it.
I just felt like it was an important city,
so I shut the song.
So I sort of felt like it was a good place to learn.
But then I stayed because there was a quarter of a million people my age all in
the city and that energy was crazy.
And then I stuck around because we were doing comedy and then all of a sudden
one day was like you said,
I woke up one day and I went,
what am I doing?
I can get the fuck out of this freezing cold,
kind of segregated,
weird city.
It's a great place to be in the beginning.
And then as you get older,
especially for a comic,
there's a,
there's a trap.
And it was a trap in Boston.
We all were aware of it.
There was a trap where you could be a local headliner and you can make good
money,
but you will never work the road.
So you'll be trapped in Boston forever.
And we all would talk about it.
There's certain guys that never got out and those guys,
they were,
they just showed us,
they showed us that there's a flaw in the system.
Yeah,
it's awesome in the beginning it's a great nest,
but you've got to leave the nest
and it's a great life lesson because New York becomes the same way.
You go to New York and you can turn into a comic that does too much crowd work.
That's to better,
that doesn't do extended bits because you know,
you can kind of scrape together a living by being in the city and doing in city
spots.
But um,
it's really important to go like,
I got a,
not that you have to come to la,
but you got to get out on the road.
Yeah.
You gotta do sets like real headlines Sense.
The New York guys,
um,
we would work with them on the road.
Sometimes they would come and do like these Bob Gonzo gigs or John Schuler gigs
in Connecticut and they couldn't headline.
Yeah.
They had these 10 minutes sets that they would do in the city.
So they would go outside the city and they try to do 40 minutes.
They just couldn't put it together
and there was no clothes,
there was no bill it.
The overall set just felt like a guy groping
and they would talk about being on the subway.
And when you talk about being on the subway in Connecticut,
they alienate you down,
not even,
you're not even into this.
Yeah.
And,
and the,
and you're used to playing on race and homosexuality because that's the audience
in New York and you go to Connecticut and they're like,
wait,
who?
What?
She's in our energy.
Totally different sort of an environment.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
man.
There's a big difference between the kind of comedy that you do when you're
starting to put together your first few minutes,
the kind of comedy you do when you want to do a TV set,
like a Letterman set or a remember like the half hour comedy hour.
Everybody wanted to get on that damn proud of those.
And then there's like a real road set.
Well you gotta,
you gotta put on a show,
it's got to start somewhere.
You take them on a little journey and it's got a wrap up tight.
Goodnight everybody.
You gotta be confident.
You're the orchestra leader,
you're the Alpha,
you're up there.
And in New York it's like,
look,
nothing is more.
I think of all those things.
Working as a club comic in New York might be the most important because it
forces you to follow guys like a tell and Louie,
whoever's coming on that night,
keep your shit together,
stay cool,
learn,
learn that people are going to be skipping,
seated and leave.
Cause they're long shows.
They'll start showing eight that goes to one in the morning.
So there's a lot of activity in the crowd.
And you just gotta.
You got to learn to deal with it.
So it's crucial,
but it's not the end.
Yeah.
It's a good place to fuck around though.
It's a good gym.
Right?
Like the comedy store's good gym for that.
You know,
that's the same sort of scenario where the show starts at 8:00 PM it goes to two
o'clock in the morning.
It's just a continuous show work.
And that's the one club I a work.
It's dark.
Yeah.
That's why I didn't used to go there cause it was so dark and I thought that
people get bumped a lot,
but now I hear it's become a really
better run.
Um,
yeah.
I hear good things have been here in better things.
Oh you don't go there?
No,
no.
Let's talk on,
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
I stopped going there in the Mitzi incident of 2007.
Yeah,
that was it for me.
February,
I think it was seven years bad.
Because you're a good fit for the road.
Yeah,
no,
I like the ice house better.
It's the same sort of thing,
but it's,
everyone's cool as fuck.
When you go there,
it's like the whole staff is just super friendly from the bike get.
I get psyched when I see the bartenders,
I get psyched when I see the manager,
like everybody a cool dude.
He loves comedy.
Bob's the best.
It's like if I have a choice between a place to work out,
I always go with the house and the audience.
I,
it's one of the weird,
weirdest things.
You walk on stage,
they're smiling at you,
you haven't even talked and they're just looking at you like,
I'm so happy you came.
Thanks for,
thanks for coming down.
Well,
those crowds that we put together when we do those shows there too,
it's like they're so positive.
There's so psyched to be there.
Right?
And then you know,
you're doing a show with,
it's like,
you know,
you're on Collins on and Dunkin's on.
It's like they're killer lineups.
So it's,
we've been doing them there for a while and it's just,
it's magical.
So when I think about going somewhere else,
like I do a little laugh factor.
Sometimes I'll do the domino rarer show or I'll do comedy juice.
The improv or fuck around there and I need to start doing the,
um,
the,
uh,
flappers in Burbank and need to start doing,
it's real good.
Also west side comedy theater.
Great.
Where's that?
So right on the promenade.
Yeah.
Santa Monica.
It's really weird.
You enter it from an alley behind the third street promenade and it's this
little theater,
but I'm telling you,
man,
these crowds are so fucking good when you go in there.
And then a Sunday and I'm doing a Sunday night and just some weeks now,
so few weeks,
let me know,
man.
I'm going to go with you.
Okay.
Neil Brennan runs it.
Neil Brennan runs a club.
Well,
he runs a night to talk to me about that.
Yeah,
that's right.
No Shit.
That's good.
Yeah.
I'll let you know.
Come down.
Oh,
I'm excited to do that.
Cause I've always said like why they used to be places on the west side.
Well,
the Improv had a place right on Santa Monica Boulevard on the west side of the
story is the original,
but it was,
the store had one in the west.
A lot of people don't know that Kinison didn't really make his beginning in the
store in Hollywood.
A lot of the sets he did were in,
um,
Brentwood.
There was a comedy show,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Close.
I don't know,
a long time before I came around,
I came around at 94,
it was already closed.
So,
um,
Kinison and the guys down there like Carla Bald,
they like ran the show completely opposite.
No,
but there was egg beast.
I couldn't work egg beats because I was dirty,
but I was hanging around with a Adam Ferrara and I used to go,
uh,
with him.
We still play pool a lot.
Adam please.
Really good.
Yeah.
And so we went to a egg B's a couple of times and he would do a set and then
we'd go play pool afterwards.
That went to Hollywood billiards used to be around.
Where was that?
Well,
it was,
it was downtown.
It was,
I forget where it was,
but there was an earthquake in [inaudible] 94,
93,
whatever.
It was fucked up the structure.
They had to condemn the building and it was a 24 hour place back then.
So then it moved to more Hollywood Hollywood and it was there until recently is
that the place was on the second floor knows downstairs actually you'd go
downstairs to get the Hollywood billiards.
Yeah,
it was a sweet spot.
And then there was the Boston,
that flooded club,
which is another pool hall that was a write off a sunset and it was an old
athletic club that they turn into a pool hall and it was great.
I use static Ferrara was a real pool hall.
It was a nice pool.
I played there with a bunch of guys play there with chimp brewer.
I used to.
That's where I met Max Everly.
And uh,
that was a,
that was a sweet spot too.
But that place went under as well.
That's great.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no pool halls left in Hollywood now.
They're all gone.
There's that one in Santa Monica.
That's pretty good.
It's a great spot.
House.
A billiards.
Yeah.
I play at the house,
a billiards in Sherman oaks.
I play the tournament there sometimes on Monday nights.
Oh,
I think,
I think you took me there once.
Great.
Yeah,
that's great.
Those are the only places left,
right?
I mean for a game like pool with a population like La is,
there's 20 million fucking people here.
I know the relay is,
I don't get la man.
Nate.
This no late night places to eat that are any good.
There's,
there's just a,
there's a lot of shit that's just missing.
Well,
there's a few places that are really good.
Like cantors cancers is great.
Answers is fucking phenomenal.
Solid New York Deli.
It's the best Pastrami in Ela.
It is.
And you can get that at two o'clock in the morning.
Right?
You can go there.
There's um,
swingers.
Swingers is really good and healthy to swingers have some really good choices.
Yeah.
But for a city as big as la,
I mean,
I could,
if I had come up with my list,
it would have been those same two restaurants,
you know,
that's it.
There's not,
you know,
norms fucking sucks.
Apparently there's a Pacific dining cart in downtown that's 24 hours a day.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The writers on Tosh were telling me how great it was.
[inaudible] Pacific dining car.
It's like a legit steakhouse.
Oh yeah.
And there's one in downtown La that's 24 hours a day.
Yeah.
So you can get a steak,
like a real legit steak at a restaurant at 4:00 AM.
Wow.
It's,
it's weird that La doesn't have the 24 hour thing in general.
Like in Ohio,
every store is open 24 hours every like,
like we had Myers that was open 24 hours.
We had department stores,
Walmarts,
we're all open 24 hours once we're all opiates,
all her stuff in Ohio is open 24 hours.
But then you go to la and it's like everything clothes,
like even even the walks out here,
like I was just in Fort Lauderdale.
I didn't realize those clubs,
nightclubs around the hardrock stay up until five o'clock in the morning.
Yeah.
And then,
and then there's like a clubs to stay open till noon that opened at midnight in
fucking Florida.
Wow.
Yeah.
And La,
two o'clock done.
People don't even stay up that late anyway.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing about La.
Why is that?
Why is everything closed up so early in New York is like 4:00 AM right.
I don't know if it's because it's like a healthy city and people get up early
and hike and do yoga and they take work more seriously.
That's a good,
another good example.
All our grocery stores are open 24 hours a day.
Like that is a good example cause people who worked the third shift,
that's tough action for them.
You know,
you want to get off work,
you get off work at four o'clock in the morning,
you want to go pick up some groceries,
you can't,
it's fucked up.
Yeah,
that's annoying.
That would be annoying.
Well,
member in Boston,
you couldn't buy alcohol on Sundays.
Oh yeah.
We used to go to New Hampshire.
The blue laws.
Right.
So stupid.
It's all the periods.
Six doesn't want you drunk.
You gotta get sober.
I say you can listen to the
the five let the Father Touched Your Pee pee.
Don't worry about it.
In Ohio we had drive through is where you can buy alcohol.
Yeah,
they have those New Hampshire doesn't Phoenix to remember any size him.
He hadn't Louisiana,
they'll give you a mixed drink,
but they have to,
it has to have a top on
it with a straw.
And the paper thing has to be covering the top of the straw.
We call it a sealed beverage.
Louisiana.
Yeah.
We had a driver once in Louisiana,
New Orleans,
great fucking guy.
And uh,
after we left,
um,
he was,
uh,
in a movement who's driving us around,
whether he was telling us about he,
he was one time I was in another place in,
in Louisiana and he was,
the cop pulled him over and he had a beer in his hand and uh,
the cop starts talking to them and asking them like questions and this and that.
He's answering the cops questions and he finishes the beer,
puts it down and pops the other beer.
And the cop goes,
what the fuck are you doing?
And he goes,
wait.
He goes,
where are you from?
And he's like,
New Orleans.
He goes,
okay,
okay.
Okay,
listen,
you can do shit there.
You can't do anywhere else.
You can't just drink a beer in front of me,
man.
That shit.
That's why I'm pulling you over in the first place.
And he goes,
I wasn't even drunk.
He wasn't even drunk.
It was just enjoying a beer.
Right?
Driving another pass.
No,
no.
He wasn't driving.
He was walking.
He was walking down the street.
All right.
He didn't see anything wrong with it.
Right.
It's not like I'm on board.
Just walking down the street.
Cop pulls me over.
Well,
what's the pot laws?
Are you allowed to smoke pot in the street?
No.
Can you spoke here in your studio?
Allegedly,
this is what's going on with pod.
Pod Is d criminalized and with decriminalized does not mean legal.
So in California it's decriminalized.
In Colorado,
it's legal.
In Colorado you can just smoke weed,
but they were trying to institute a law in Colorado where they would,
they would bring out these,
these sensors and they would have these things.
They attach their nose,
they look preposterous.
It looked like something from a doctor Seuss book come to life and it's this
thing that literally goes over your nose and it looks like a bullhorn.
And they would sniff through it and if they could detect x parts per million of
marijuana outside of your residence,
they could go and arrest you or finding it.
Right.
I heard about it.
Yeah.
But they,
everybody was,
everybody was so negative against it that I'm pretty sure that they dropped it
because people were so angry.
Like how stupid that was.
Very 1984.
No,
only that.
Okay.
Gives people the ability to stand outside.
It's,
you know what it is.
It's people that were for the longest time enforcing a policy.
That's not,
that's not valid anymore.
There's the things that guys knows that Shit's real.
Looks like the type of asshole smell or the,
look,
he's already frowning lean.
Well that guy needs,
we'd more than anybody.
Right,
right.
Put a smile on his face.
Silly Bitch.
But,
um,
yeah,
I was just in Colorado and I didn't get a chance to read.
But like couple of the comics I talked to,
one of them isn't even doing comedy much because he's doing pot tours.
So what everybody's doing now for money in Colorado,
they just do comedy and pop shops.
No,
no.
That pot tour,
if people come in to Colorado to go drive when you drive them around,
I don't think that they can technically buy it.
I think you need a Colorado license to buy it in the shops,
but
you can walk through the shop and smell it and then not buy it for you.
And then they go out and smoke it and it's like a whole tour and they make,
they're making fucking tons of money.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So the probably have material that they do just for the pot tours.
Oh,
I'm sure there.
Yeah.
They'd probably have a bunch of other corner pod jokes,
but they said it's great for the economy pay.
Everybody's making money.
Oh,
it's unbelievable.
For the economy,
the and that's what that fat fuck from New Jersey,
the dummy that governor Chris Christie,
that fucking silly cunt.
He was like,
it'll never be there on my watch.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and he cites some unbelievably unscientific study that came out of some major
university,
which is like a headshot foundation.
I don't know what the study was,
but it was about abnormalities and a marijuana.
The abnormalities it causes in the brain.
What does that mean?
Well,
here's what it means.
What's normal?
Okay.
It just because something has a certain content in it or your mind reacts a
certain way without a drug,
with the idea that that it changing being bad,
you would have to demonstrate that there's something wrong with the people that
it's changing.
Like what are you,
what are you demonstrating that shows that this abnormality isn't any way
detrimental?
Like what are you showing?
Like where all these people,
they're smoking pot.
That of becoming shaking messages where all these people that are smoking pot,
millions upon millions upon millions of people are smoking pot on a daily basis.
Why is everybody,
are they falling apart?
Is everyone losing their job,
but if you're getting a drive,
are they looking at their phone going,
what the fuck is this?
You know,
this is not happening.
You're not demonstrating any negative effects.
You're saying the study shows a negative effect.
No,
it doesn't.
This study shows a change.
You can commission a study to say anything you want.
Well,
when you look at the word,
the language in that study,
it's not scientific at all.
The language is creepy because the language says in one of the quotes,
I'm paraphrasing it.
It was something along the lines of,
you know,
people that think that smoking pot,
even on a casual basis is,
is fine.
This studies showing that it's not good at all.
Like you can't say not good at all because you're not,
you're not demonstrating not good.
When you're demonstrating is a change,
guess what else changes your fucking personality,
your creativity,
your compassion sex,
your sensitivity to sexual intercourse,
the way food tastes in your mouth,
your way,
you view other people,
your senses going down.
There's a lot of things are going on.
Well these and these are the same people that will disagree with 98% of the
scientists around the world who say there's climate change.
Yeah.
Then are hard studies with real numbers that are scientific.
Well,
this Chris Christie guys,
fat as fuck,
which is one of the worst things you could be as a person if you want to be
healthy,
shows a lack of character.
It does.
It shows a lack of willpower.
It shows a lack of focus and determination.
You look what do you,
how do you view life and you,
you're going around in a sloppy meat wagon.
That's what you are.
You're,
you're not an athlete.
You're not someone that if you had a choice between being a person who respects
their body and treats it well,
or being a person that treats their body like a fucking big Mac dumpster once
your choice,
well,
you went with big Mac dumpster.
Well guess what?
You don't get to lead because you're not a leader.
You don't get to decide what's healthy when you're walking around like
[inaudible] you're going to have a heart attack.
Yeah.
I think there was a study that showed that people wouldn't vote for him because
they'd be afraid that he would die in office of a heart attack.
He could die of sleep apnea for sure.
He has sleep apnea.
When you're that fat,
you have sleep apnea.
Yeah,
he'd probably snores like how?
I don't know if he sleeps with a seat CPAP machine.
If he does and he should.
There's a lot of shit going on,
but there's,
that guy's probably got on diapers,
a seed pack.
We Shane,
he's got a big Mac next to his bedside table.
There's a diaper that they're selling now.
Totally.
I'm told me Tara Gousha for as a lot of times a menu.
You fucker,
you get a little drippage is a Tampon that you were at the front of your diaper
cause your Dick leaks man and they're trying to sell it as like a normal thing.
Yeah.
I mean while it's this guy with this swollen,
inflated gut filled with undigested food and feces that hasn't been pushed out
yet.
Yeah.
Fat that permeates all the different layers of his skin and tissue
muscle left under there.
The muscles are all gone.
I'm here to throw you.
Dick came broken.
I mean to tell you my Dick's leaking.
Trust me.
Just wear a Tampon.
Keep leading them.
Fucking meatball subs.
Volition.
Fuck girlish over here with these meatballs.
Got me balls and saw they got Monica God.
They got good at little peppers to get the good peppers they put on the top day
society like my mother,
bless her soul.
God bless her.
She died of a heart attack at 51 she weighed 300 pounds.
He's the guy driving the truck that beeped at me.
Fucking God got ahead and make back,
Eh,
I got my fucking peppers.
She,
I got my meatballs.
I know when I walk my,
the fat on my feet spills over the outside of my sneakers.
I like how that looks like a little waterfall into my heel who have my step
down.
Just who's over rolls over.
I liked,
I liked the wattle cause my fucking guns,
my gun sticking out.
My legs can't stay the way the back of my head looks to the hot dog roll.
Look,
I look fat sausages that are grown out of the base of my skull.
Just you.
It looks like it makes you hungry for the fucking,
the either the fucking nice assume sausage.
I like,
look at my face.
You see a wrinkle in my face.
You see any spider mocks by my eyes?
Fuck no,
because the flesh is pushing out against the skin all the time.
It's pulled tight.
It makes me look young and vibrant.
Look at my Chin's tight.
All of them
I had to do to told me that that was William Shaffner's.
William Soccer for said this to him.
He said,
uh,
he goes,
wow.
He was interviewing them and we're shocked.
Apparently he's like 80 years old.
And he goes,
you look great.
And he said,
well,
I realized that a certain year that if I just put on five pounds a year,
I never get really wrinkly because my face is like pushing fat out.
Right?
Like,
and he goes,
I'm serious.
Like apparently like he,
it was a strategy to like to stay young looking like,
but keeping your fake.
But I don't think you're supposed to be that fat when you're 80 I think that's
like super bad for you.
Right.
That's just bullshit.
Like cause he's fat.
He's just made that shit.
Right.
He's working backwards.
But it is true.
If you'll get older fat people,
they look way better than fat joggers or then older joggers.
No,
I started running two years ago and I lost weight in my face and now I look like
a fucking skull.
I take my hat,
I looked like a look at this.
When I tell you I had,
I looked like a light bulb.
There's no,
the light hits it and there's just like a,
I just all my face and sunken and you liked it better when you have like a
little plump edge.
I wasn't even plugged,
but this is like,
Eh,
it received at my chin.
Looks like it's sticking out and I don't know how to put weight on in my face.
You know?
That's once it's gone,
it's gone.
Yeah.
That's the thing that happens with a women.
They get fat injections in their face because you're,
as you get older,
you're thin.
You tend to thin out in the face makes a lot of,
I'm not like the way that looks.
So they get those crazy fillers too.
You see the fillers now?
Ooh,
that's a regretful decision that they decided to do this.
It's not silicon.
It's like actual tissue.
What it is man.
I mean sometimes they do,
they do do it with fat,
but they use artificial fillers on their faces and when they use filler it,
you've given this like pull up some images to try to be kind.
Some find one that has a woman's face blacked out or something,
so we don't have to mock her.
But these poor people,
they,
they go to these doctors and they get this stuff injected in their face and it
makes it look like someone beat them up,
like their cheek start puffing out and the cheek puffing out look sort of like
diminishes wrinkles and it gives us like fuller effect,
but it looks so monster life.
Yeah.
There's a lady at my daughter's school and she seems to be in real nice lady,
but
oh,
that's a bad example.
That's a lady who did it at seven 11 yeah,
that's about,
that's someone who did it badly.
I was wondering like,
you know
if you're married and you get a face lift or a boob job,
you really just think like you get ready to leave your husband because he
doesn't give a fuck.
I bet he gives a fuck.
Maybe he wants to.
Maybe it's a woman's idea.
Maybe it's the man's idea.
You know,
every,
every situation is different,
but some guys get psyched.
It's like,
Hey,
my wife could have booked Jeff.
I want to see a picture.
Big Touch.
No fucker.
You want to fuck.
Come on Bro.
Fuck my wife.
Come on.
It's the way that juicy Posey,
she had a couple of babies but they tied it up nicely.
Tighten up the under carriage.
We tossed a little bit of a silicon down on the taint strip cause all your
before and after.
I feels like a baby's fist.
Yeah.
Let's not show this poor woman.
I don't,
that's not a good example either.
Some people really get away with it like,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Found generous.
Got a work done,
but she looks,
can you pull up a before or after on Ellen?
I don't know if she's doing exercise.
They're taking vitamins,
whatever it is.
Her face
looks 20 years younger than it used still.
It's called having $1 billion.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure.
Probably as doctors injecting fetus cells into her body on a daily basis,
any of that kind of cash fetus cells she had.
So she had some house that she just sold recently.
The,
you know,
it was like on a website that showed the house like,
oh my God,
so fucking $28 million house was,
she bought Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston's house.
They built it and then they,
uh,
which,
which she used to,
now that's not the example,
Brian.
He just nailed it.
Wow.
Look what she used to look like.
That was crazy.
But the one on the right would still be the before.
There's an after that shows her face much more filled out.
Uh,
less,
less deep lines.
Um,
do you worked for her to avid say the first two years of the show,
what was that large?
I won four Emmy's.
That's really good.
Yeah.
What was it like though working there?
The Emmy's or a heavy and they're gold says my name on them.
Hmm.
I understand.
Made a lot of money.
I was on daily,
probably was,
I know he's a superhero,
is that right?
Yeah,
I was just up as,
uh,
they,
they just grabbed people off of this park bench and they were like meet at this
park bench,
hang out on park.
And I was,
I was just,
I was in Burbank.
They filmed me in Burbank and uh,
I was driving and just when Twitter first,
she first got on Twitter and she tweeted something like egg meet,
meet at this bench in the next five minutes,
dresses up as a superhero.
So I was driving and I'm like,
that's the binge and why was driving by,
so I just like pulled over real quick and like tried to make something out of
shit that I had in my car.
And so I just dressed up in all blue and light blue scrubs.
It was my girlfriend girlfriend's like,
er scrubs shit.
And I made myself look like the blue guy from a,
what's that movie?
Avatar?
No,
the doctor.
Manhattan.
Yeah,
the watchman.
Now I even had a dick also cause I had a sleeve.
Where did you get the deck?
I had a sleep.
I had a sleeve put like a pillow in it to make it look like a dick.
So I like like walked out with like a fake Dick.
It's tiny.
You got on TV?
Yeah.
Very creative.
When you consider the fuck is,
this was all constructed based on things that he had the sliding around in his
car,
right?
Yeah.
Use Condoms.
Starbucks cut the shows.
A level of commitment that neither you nor I would have because what's the big,
what's the pay off?
No pay off.
He gets to meet Ellen.
Did you see the new video of Rob Ford got busted smoking crack again?
No,
he's going to rehab now.
We've got busted.
Slept in the commitment.
I love the commitment of a drug deal or video tapes him.
Oh
yeah,
she goes dancing and then she's talking about how I just got Twitter and then
I'm sitting at this,
hey,
why is she wearing a tie?
There's,
I like to wear ties.
I friends with this guy also,
but she's a woman,
but she's a lesbian.
Oh,
you didn't know that.
There's now big stupid Dick that's,
you
have to go back pillow.
I'm such a terrible a superhero.
That's the dumbest superhero ever actually get to meet her in person though.
Yeah.
And she showed me a bunch of presence and when we were on the whole episode,
like she kept on going back to us and wow.
Yeah,
she does have a tie on just like at God.
That's weird.
I still have that shirt,
my tweets or what does the shirt say?
Oh that's cool.
Great.
As a,
we did this thing for Christmas,
the 12 days of Christmas.
And so they would kind of like Oprah.
Like you get a car and you get a car.
But every day for like 30 days leading up to Christmas,
they gave the audience something huge.
And so as a producer we got whatever it was every day.
So one day I'd come home with like a Dyson vacuum cleaner.
The next day was like a Posturepedic mattress.
Uh,
you know,
it was like crazy big gifts.
You know,
at the time an iPod was a big deal.
They had just come out,
you got iPods one day,
fucking TV set the next.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
There's a lot of Schwag promoting stuff on television.
Like if you're on television and you're promoting items,
like to think of the impact that must have to have your product on the pipe,
the prices,
right.
Or something like that.
That's what people understand with product placement.
It's like,
you know,
people probably send you shit.
Right.
And you talk about it on your shell.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean think about what that's worth you talking about something on the shell.
More people should send you stuff.
No,
I'm sending it out right now.
Laying around here.
Yeah,
there's too much stuff,
but it's nice to be able to help people to look.
You find out about something that you really liked get to.
Yeah.
This dude is down in,
um,
Chile and they're taking this so much plastic and the,
uh,
in the ocean.
And so they're taking it all and a fisherman,
a lot of it is fish,
fish nets,
fishermen's nets,
and they take it and recycle it and making it a skateboards.
And now they're,
they're selling them all over the country.
So yeah.
Dude's gonna come in,
he's sending me escape you,
me and my son make skateboards together.
So he heard about that.
So He's,
he's sending me a bunch and then he's going to come in and do the show.
He's doing a tour of the U s selling escape.
So how do they,
how do they extract it from the ocean?
The fishermen collect it and bring it into the guy.
Oh,
that's a good move.
You make it worth something like Cam.
Right.
Thanks.
That's actually probably the smartest move when it comes to figuring out how to
do that garbage patch in the middle of the Pacific.
Because if they can make it so that it's like a recyclable,
like,
you know,
just like cans are worth x amount of dollars.
If you could bring in x amount of plastic waste and then companies would want to
develop some sort of a,
that's like here's $1 billion worth of plastic waste just floating around the
ocean.
If you can figure out how to extract it,
you could profit.
So I might spend millions to try to extract billions.
Right,
right.
And it's um,
it's also like a,
how do you get people to,
I think it's the iPhones,
they have a covering on the,
on the face of it that's titanium or it's some kind of metal that's really
precious
that in Africa it's another one.
He sinks where there is mines where people are killing me.
Java think to think of a coal town.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a conductivity,
uh,
item,
I think aids and conductivity.
It's inside the actual phone itself.
Yeah.
They need,
they need a better program to recycle phones.
A lot of them are getting thrown out.
Yeah.
No,
but you're right man.
They also need another way to do it when they don't have to use these conflict
minerals.
Yeah.
There's a phone that they came out with,
so it's like a Karma free phone.
Like that was what we call that.
We started calling the Karma free phone.
But what was it?
What's the name of that phone?
It did come out.
Well,
why don't you look it up?
It was,
she'd make a flip phone out of it.
Well it was that make a flip phone.
There was a,
there was a phone that it came out like a year ago,
but the issue about it was that it was only three g.
It wasn't four g.
L t e people like,
well I want Karma but I want
get my email really quick.
Anything,
man.
It's so funny.
It is funny.
Yeah.
I mean we want,
we want it all.
We can't take a step back.
It's,
it's crazy and I get caught up in it.
I get all the latest shit.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a good one though.
That's a good one because it was like,
it was almost like a test for the human race.
You know,
it's a great android phone.
It's very beautiful.
It's kind of Nice screen,
but it only has three j what?
Eh,
I mean that one that they make with babies and isn't that amazing?
Because it was personal in your life.
If somebody said,
if you do x,
your child will be killed.
Or if you do x,
uh,
somebody's going to get their arm cut off by the John Jewy somewhere in the
Congo to get it,
then you wouldn't do it.
But,
but somehow because it's far away place,
we don't take the exact connection that we know about that.
If you buy this product,
you're supporting this and somehow it doesn't mean anything to us.
I'm talking about myself.
No tool.
Almost everybody.
If it's not as good,
you don't care.
You're like,
fuck,
I don't want the best shit.
I've always had the best shit.
The Best Shit's always what I've been reaching for right now.
The best shifts here,
and there's this new thing,
it's called a Fairphone.
Once you play the video because they have a video on their website.
Do you think that if you knew that every time you masturbated,
you would lose 10 minutes from your life?
Do you think you would stop masturbating or would you do it in a controlled way
or would you just say,
fuck it?
I think you'd say fog it cause your life without masturbating would be so
frustrating.
It's like whatever,
10 minutes you give up,
it's a lot of 10 minutes in a day.
I mean,
if you're a maniac and you jerk off every day,
five times a day,
you're gonna have a real problem.
But if you're one of those once every few day guy,
yeah.
What are you giving up?
Giving up 30 minutes a month?
Who gives a shit
30 this year?
What is it?
Same.
But what we don't have
a clue
about what's inside this stuff.
We don't know where it comes from or who made it.
We know almost nothing about our stuff.
That's why we started with an alternative for the thing.
We can't live without
our phone.
We the people their phone
today and this,
this is what we're building
a smart is on the phones,
but fan,
which makes it more than a photo.
It's a beginning step in the right direction and we're making it happen.
A small phone.
This made in a way that puts people and environment.
Yeah,
they looked happy.
We'll already working hard on the first batch.
We're much there unless way you come in,
just don't making them.
We need you to preorder.
It caused what?
Buying and owning this phone,
you can make a difference and you become a part of change by or five stalls and
movement at Fairfield,
fine.com
it sounds like a good idea.
However,
you're not getting my money before I see your fucking product.
Yeah.
I want it reviewed before I buy it.
It's going to suck.
I'm not going to Kickstarter my fucking life.
You know like your whole life depends on your phone.
They're going to use the android operating system,
which is no nice and established and it works and everything like that.
But I need to know that it's not just a terrible,
horrible piece of shit before I give you to make a prototype and put it out to
the reviewers so they can let me know if it's worth your money.
Yeah.
And you also like this,
the reason why people invest in companies,
like you bring in investors,
you don't get it from white getting it Kickstarter style for a phone.
That's just,
that's not a smart thing for a person who invest in.
Right.
I mean,
I guess the thinking behind it might be if a corporation comes in and they're
going to demand that you use those metals because they want the pricing as low
as possible and you know,
uh,
but if you would,
they definitely though,
I mean,
does it seem,
it doesn't seem like to me that it's impossible to find an ethical company,
right?
There's companies out there that would look at what they're doing and say this,
love it.
I mean,
I'm watching the commercial,
I'm like,
I love this.
It makes,
it makes you feel good.
I mean,
I want to buy shit that makes me feel good.
I think a lot of people respond to that now.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's all conflict free too.
I wonder if they use Colton.
I wonder,
you know,
it said titanium and aluminum conflict free.
Right?
That's what one said.
It's,
it's well,
even if it's a step in the right direction,
it's worth it.
Yeah.
Well,
it's nice that people are thinking that way.
They,
they also,
and they also realize that there's a market for it.
That's the other thing that's nice is it blew people away with the Prius.
They had no idea it would be as successful as it was.
People felt good buying it.
I drive one and I hate it.
I want a Mustang and a half to drive.
My car wins.
Yeah.
We'll drive around the neighborhood.
Go really fast after this.
Yes.
It'll change.
Your life is going to be awkward if I get an erection while we're driving.
No,
no,
no.
I'll be fine.
Just don't beat off on my dashboard.
Show.
Take care of that direction.
Yeah.
I'll just handle it for you,
my friend.
This is going to be a good ride.
I had a buddy jerked his
dog off,
jerked his dog off with his foot and I go,
why?
He goes,
because he needs relief.
See what the dog would lie on its back and he'd put his foot on the dog's Dick
and go like this and it talks Dick and talk.
It's squirt all over his stomach.
You don't talk to this friend anymore?
I hope.
No.
Well,
you know what's amazing about that is it's illegal.
Even though the dog like my dog,
every time I pet my dog,
he tries to put his dick in my hand.
So who's the victim?
Who's the victim and the crime?
Is it illegal to jerk your dog?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
It's okay to finger,
but you can't jerk it off
now.
But that which means I was thinking about this.
It means that if there's a law against jerking off your dog,
that means that some congressmen stood on the floor and said he proposed a bill
saying you can't jerk off your dog and every other congress and looked down and
went,
just guys.
Jared got off his dog.
Yeah,
this guys angry.
He's angry at his own instincts.
It's the only way he thinks he can stop is if there's a law against it.
Crazy.
Son of a bitch.
What are you trying to call?
Did you hear about that?
Can KKK guy who,
uh,
who's,
I think he's one of the ones that just shot up a,
a school recently.
It turned out that they had busted him years back with a male prostitute of
black male prostitutes.
Wow.
And he's like this anti gay K K K cat,
probably all about family because the KKK is all about family.
They'll tell you,
this is so many people that are like that,
just angry at it because they're,
it's in their system when they're just fighting it.
They're fighting off the gay.
Are they fighting off the wanting to fuck dogs?
Right.
It is
busted with black male prostitute,
Grand Dragon.
He killed three people outside of the Jewish center in Kansas and they turned
out to not even be Jewish.
So he failed on three counts.
Number one,
he didn't even kill the people who supposed to hate number two,
he's fucking,
he's not,
he could have been a hero if he'd shot real Jewish people,
but then he would have been rejected because then all his brother is the KKK.
Know that he was fucking a black male prostitute.
Well now they know but he's going to say that that's just propaganda.
That's what it is.
The government
gay star is going to say this is the best website ever.
What
you should do a segment on your show where every episode you check in on the top
stories on Gay Star News.
I'm for it.
It's pretty smart.
That will be funny on a podcast to find some really obscure specific website and
just check on it every week.
You know like uh,
like a,
you know tulip growers.com
we'd have to be careful with what you promote though.
Cause if you gay star news.com turned out to be like propaganda,
like the onion for gay news turned out to be satire and means satire.
Yeah.
There's that.
There's so of these fake news
websites I hate like there's that Joe Rogan one that got banned from the UFC
cause you failed your drug test that's going around right now that everyone
thinks it's real.
Yeah.
Everyone thinks it's real.
So much so that a friend of mine sent me a text saying how much it was bullshit.
Like this is crazy.
They're out of their mind.
Oh God.
The guy came up that idea got fired.
Like,
oh Christ,
what is it?
There's a website that made a parody.
Things saying that I got drug tested at the UFC and I failed my drug test,
so they suspended me.
Oh no shit.
And then they fired the guy who came up with the idea to drug test me.
He's now fired.
Like the whole thing is so stupid.
It's all fake.
It's someone just made it up.
But it's not even funny.
It's like that's the thing that people are doing these days.
They just make up stories like the onion.
We'll make something up.
But it would be so ridiculous that it's funny.
Yeah,
but these,
these guys aren't doing that.
They're just making up stories.
It's like they call themselves,
they call themselves a parody website,
but most people don't realize the parody website.
So even if it says in a disclaimer,
you know,
everything on this side,
it's full of shit.
Even it says that you don't read that you read the fucking story because you get
a link to the stories.
Right.
Click on the link,
you go to it,
you go,
oh my God,
I can't believe they would do this.
You send it to a million other people.
They sent it to a million people.
You read it on your phone.
You're at,
at the
getting the context of it.
You're never seeing the disclaimer.
Exactly.
If somebody googles Joe Rogan and UFC that might lead them to that,
right to the article.
Probably been seen by hundreds of thousands of people already,
Christ and passed on.
I mean,
it hit me on Twitter.
Who knows how many times it makes it into the mainstream press in anyone?
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's pretty obvious.
I'll do it.
I mean,
they have been duped before,
right.
You know,
where people didn't do their due diligence,
but I think the mainstream press is a little bit more aware of that now.
So they'll go and look at the source and then say,
Oh look,
this is a parody site.
Yeah.
People look for a parody site.
Like right away now,
but they,
CNN
duped.
It seems like weekly they get fucking caught on something.
I remember I went to Boston bombing.
Remember they pointed out and the suspect who was not a suspect and people
surrounded his house and his name is probably still shit because people won't
even forget.
They'll forget that it wasn't right.
Right.
Like you remember that guy,
the Atlanta bomber,
the Olympic bomber.
Yeah.
I didn't do anything and they accused him of it.
He was a security guard.
They might get ruined,
ruined him,
ruined them.
And they must trust that guy got because of that hate that guy got because of
that must've been unbearable.
Everywhere you go,
people think you're a terrorist.
You're getting death threats on a regular basis.
Some dude is in his car right now loading up his gun,
driving from Louisiana to your house,
cause he wants to defend America.
Right.
He knows where it is.
I know where that mother fucker lives.
It's time to rock and roll and fucking gets in his car and starts driving.
You cause of cause of seeing him.
What's he listening to on the radio right?
I love
food and
I'm driving over poop.
Andrew Orleans width on the wheel bearing down
Kevin Meeney right after nine 11 he was the airport in San Francisco with his
wife and kid and like his daughter ran through airport security and she was
young.
She was like three and he went to go get her and the police grabbed him and he
struggled and he got arrested and got into the press that he was and you got to
remember how sensitive this was.
It got,
you know,
they wrote it that he was like fucking with airport security and he got blown
up.
It was fucking brutal.
It was all all over the news.
You don't remember that.
I remember that.
Now that you bring it up.
Yeah,
that was crazy.
The airport security,
you can get really wacky with the rules and you know,
the not understanding that it's a fucking three year old,
the most ridiculous thing ever.
Like you're going to try a person with three year old's not going to be a
terrorist.
You dip shit.
They,
the average person with three year old,
three year olds saying,
Daddy,
is that Daddy?
Yeah.
Relax,
relax.
Let the guy go back through.
Everything's going to be fine.
Yeah.
Well it's,
you know,
it's,
it's getting to the point where they,
there's,
you gotta have some profiling.
I mean,
that's why ll the Israeli airlines never had a terrorist strike because why
don't we follow their methods,
which is take a look at situations like that and put it lower on the priorities
and then take people like yourself with a shaved head.
It's kind of bulky.
You've got that look in your eye and a swat you down,
you know,
get it.
Get a cavity search going.
I think it's the same thing that leads people to shoot dogs.
It's just an abuse of power situation.
You know?
It's the same thing where they know they can get away with it.
So they do it and they're frustrated and that role,
just look at it.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
They're patting down these little kids combing through the hair.
Look,
they're looking in the hair.
That's not real.
It's totally real.
So 100% real.
They do do.
They're grabbing her ass.
Yeah.
They have to make sure it's a real ass.
It could be a bomb.
Holy Shit.
Look at that.
They're touching.
Are they Middle Eastern?
Is that why they're doing it?
Who knows?
They look kind of Middle East.
Doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Wow.
People are fucking crazy.
And I'm glad people make this.
Yeah.
That,
that parents supposedly did this,
uh,
filmed it of the two.
These two kids going on forever.
I've never know.
So stupid.
Shut it off,
man.
It's making me,
so usually they just grab,
they don't grab your Dick,
but they touch you.
And then they go to the,
they just graze the size of your penis on the front of your leg to make sure
it's on a bullet.
You think my penis looks like a bullet missile.
I like a missile.
Right,
right,
right.
No little bullet.
No,
no.
Like I'll fucking go fucking sausage
for the feast.
San Genero.
You know,
we'd go down a little bit when we get the fucking sausage,
the sausage,
they put the peppers,
you know,
they got the moon Yeesh and they thought the bread they use,
it's like a mama used to meg.
What they used to fax your back.
A Moblers thrown though.
You went with Youso fashion.
Do you remember that?
Fucking that festivals engineer but was on my block.
I lived on Mulberry Street.
That's right.
People to send in my lobby.
I was like,
I can't believe this crazy
asshole lives here.
Right.
You lived like in the heart of little Italy.
Right in between Prince and spring on a five story walk up with John.
Why did you choose to live there?
What was that about?
Well,
you remember,
uh,
Paul Lyons,
comedian,
his guy who had,
he had an opening,
I was moving to New York and he said,
this is a,
I can sublet my,
my unit.
And I moved,
I moved in there for three months and I fell in love with the neighborhood.
I was all like,
you know,
everyone knew each other and everybody was a character and I met a couple of
Nice people in the building.
So place opened up next door and it was a,
it was a one bedroom connected to a studio and they'd eat illegally,
popped out the door in between and raised a family there for like 40 years.
And it was Tony and Gladys Ray Goo.
And so they,
uh,
and they and I,
I met them and they were,
they had a place around the corner there,
son Tony,
who works in construction.
He lives in Staten Island now,
a nice house.
He bought the Macondo around the,
around the corner because they were too old to climb up those steps anymore.
So they're going to sublet it to me.
I mean,
they still play like 400 bucks for this unit.
And they were paying like 200 bucks was rent controlled and every and every,
maybe I was paying like 600 and every month I'd walk around the corner and I had
to pay them in cash.
But I'd go around and first I would,
they,
they'd make me a Cappuccino that have canolas and I would give them a $400 in
cash.
And then when Tony would leave the room,
I'd give Gladys the other 200 on the side.
That's my bingo money.
Tony doesn't need to know about that.
No Way.
And when I first moved to two different prices to different prices,
there was a little kickback.
And then the place was literally one door over in,
upstairs from,
from the um,
uh,
what was the club that,
um,
that God,
he belonged to the,
where he was arrested.
And so,
uh,
so social club
shit.
But,
but Tony says to me,
anything ever happens to you?
You tell me.
Cause you know,
I know people,
I'm not,
not going to say,
well I know,
but,
uh,
I think you know who I knew and uh,
and so like,
and so we,
I opened up that they left their furniture and it was all like literally the
plastic on the couch.
It was everything had like a,
for Micah on it.
And the end table had,
uh,
an eavesdropping device on the phone and it had bullet casings.
Whoa.
And it was like,
everything was just really fucking weird.
But Reaganite the Raven I'd social club.
Exactly.
Apparently they were there.
The associates frequented by John Gotti and his associates in the late 1970s in
1980s.
Yeah,
around 1990 Federal Bureau of Investigation was able to infiltrate the mafia
using secret electronic surveillance.
Well,
you know what they did?
They couldn't bug the place.
They bug the place itself and then they found it.
So what they started doing was God,
he and his would walk up and
down Mulberry Street and have conversations.
So what the FBI did was they started parking cars on Mulberry Street and putting
eavesdropping devices in the hubcaps,
the cars.
So they would pick it up as they were moving.
They would grab the conversation and that's how they actually put them away.
Wow.
Yeah.
And every shop on the street,
there was pictures of God he up,
they fucking love this guy.
And then at the time there was this one dude who was a,
he was up on charges,
so he was trying to get an insanity plea.
So He'd walk around the neighborhood and Pajamas,
Vincent the Chin Get Janti.
Is that his name?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
He,
you,
uh,
not only did they do that,
but when they would talk about him,
they would just point to their chin.
They would go and it was probably a good idea,
but you know,
he's,
you got to know about it.
Oh Shit.
There are points of the Chin and then they would know who they were talking
about it.
He didn't allow anybody to use his name and he would pretend to be crazy.
So yeah,
walk around shuffle.
I don't think it worked.
I think he,
I think we're talking about them right now.
So
we know we're pretty far on the outside.
Well,
the A,
and then there was this woman named Gina and she had these three dogs and she'd
walk around,
I mean literally did laps of the neighborhood just walking around and she ran
the numbers and if you wanted to bet on the numbers you'd give her,
he'd give her money.
And then,
you know how they picked the numbers is the last three numbers of the person
aqueduct.
The day before.
Those were the three numbers and whatever it was,
they paid out on it and she was all cash and she would go,
there was the shark bar on the corner and uh,
that was like a main place you hung out.
But I mean,
just walking and people walking up to her shaking her hand,
given a,
like a dollar,
here's a dollar on three 87.
Yeah,
my grandmother used to do that.
Itchy.
My grandmother went to jail for six months because she,
uh,
she's running numbers and um,
they wanted her to rat out the mob.
She wouldn't do it.
She was running the numbers sell.
She was selling.
I mean,
she was moving around,
she was doing it for the mob,
but you know how it works,
you know,
they'll have someone go and,
place bets and talk to this and Marjorie wants 50 on that.
And Gina,
you know,
thinks this is her numbers.
She would collect the numbers and she then she'd bring them the whole,
you know,
she wasn't like making a ton of money off of it.
Right.
But they wanted her to rollover.
Yeah.
So my grandmother went to jail for six months and we would go to those.
She was in jail.
Not until later.
I was not until I was like a teenager.
Yeah.
I thought that she would just was visiting.
Her aunt was like,
where's the,
where's grandma?
Grandma's with aunt Mary.
That was always the story.
So she,
for six months,
she was in the pokey.
She would knit fucking sweaters for the guards and Shit,
you know?
But just kept her in jail.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Pretty hard.
You never talked to her about it?
No.
She would have never admitted to me anyway.
True to my grandmother wore a wig and she was crazy.
Yeah.
She was always sidekick.
You know,
there was always a ghost nearby was like,
there was a lot of,
oh,
she was nuts.
Yeah.
She was a really eccentric woman.
That's a fine grandma to have though,
is I had Martin King,
she had a monkey.
She danky named Chichi that used to live in the attic and he would bite people,
cheat.
She would chew gum.
You give Chia pet sticker gum.
He'd open up the gum,
take it out of the wrapper and put it in his mouth,
chew it and look at you all fucking crazy.
Scream at the kids came near me would start screaming and climb on her.
Yeah,
she had a monkey.
My fucking grandfather hated that monkey.
Oh my God.
He must have loved visiting her.
Oh,
it was fascinating.
But it was the main reason why I was averse to relationships.
That and my,
my own parents' relationship,
which was horrific when I was a little kid.
My Real Dad and my Stepdad is a great guy and he's been with me since I was like
seven years old.
He's a sweetheart.
Like he's never,
uh,
never hit my mom once.
But the fights that my mom and my dad got into before my mom left when I was
little,
I was like five years old were horrific.
And I remember violence and screaming.
It was really,
really hard to like ever think about wanting to be in a relationship because of
that and that grandparents and screaming at each other.
Now grandparents wasn't violent,
but my grandmother would like,
they're both named Joe was Josephine and uh,
my grandfather was Joseph Joseppe,
but you know,
in Italy they would call them that in America,
call him Joseph,
but they would fucking scream at each other screaming match Rashmi Joe,
because my grandmother was late for everything.
He would have to tell her that something was at two o'clock if it was at six
like this bitch was just late.
She was always,
she wanted to put her wig on again.
This wig doesn't work.
I need another wig.
And she put it another wig on.
It was just craziness.
Yeah.
She was always putting food together.
Like she was a killer cook,
so she'd always like make homemade pasta and she would like,
if she would like,
say we all had to meet somewhere,
like my grandmother was not just not going to be ready on time.
If there was a family gathering and everybody was meeting at six o'clock you
know,
my grandfather would be all frazzled and they would be screaming at each other
just so I all,
I would ever,
I would associate relationships with screaming at each other and possibly
hitting each other.
That's what I saw.
So I was like,
fuck all that.
I before seven.
I mean,
you,
you know this with kids.
I mean,
your kids are getting to that age where it's like you did the,
the learning happens in the first like Ericsson,
you know,
uh,
Freud,
they all say the learning happens in the first five,
six years after that.
You just corralling them.
There's a little bit of that.
I mean,
you're certainly changing the way they interact with people.
You shape it and I don't totally buy it.
I think there's a lot of times that's when people stopped paying attention.
They,
they have them for our first couple of years.
They'd do that and then they think,
wow,
the kids can walk.
Yeah.
The kid can talk and they sort of just let them walk and talking the wall.
You know,
I'm also,
their learning is done within the first couple of years.
I ain't get to say that because I've learned and grown as an adult.
You have a year,
an exception.
You're no,
you really are.
I mean,
I've said this before on the show.
Like I,
I've known you,
I feel like before and after,
not that before was bad,
but your energy changed so dramatically and I think you're,
um,
part of it
is we were young so we were so hungry to make it that we were just,
you know,
competitive and fucking,
the anger was working in a good way,
but then you,
you changed and that's rare.
A lot of them,
a lot of people don't change.
Most people don't change at all.
Well,
I came from a crazy competitive,
the world of martial arts competition growing up,
doing that like that in forming my personality through high school,
competing in mixed martial arts,
martial arts tournaments,
full contact taekwondo tournaments and stuff.
It was just too violent.
Right.
The idea of that being what shapes your life and then trying to interject
yourself into a normal society,
like you're always on hair trigger.
You always ready to smash things.
They're always ready to fight.
It's like,
it's a really weird way to develop as a human being.
So it took me a long time to calm that down.
Mm.
Yeah.
Because if you were raised with that kind of anger and that kind of physical
violence,
then the martial arts was actually taking that and putting more focus on it and
developing it as opposed to developing other facets of your personality.
Sort of.
Um,
it w w certainly controlled at though too,
in a way better way than just,
you know,
being angry,
wandering through the city,
like training and discipline and focus.
The character development of martial arts had a huge impact on just me moving
out of where I was when I was a young boy to move in where I was as a young man.
So even though I might've been more prone to having violent tendencies because
of my background,
it was way more in control because of martial arts.
Way More in control,
but it's just,
it wasn't just martial arts,
it was competing.
Just the,
the,
the hardcore competition of national tournament's was just,
it's really fucked with you.
It fucks with your brain to wires your brain in a very strange way because it
would be prepare for a tournament,
be terrified,
fight,
be relieved for a little while,
a little while,
and then,
okay,
when's the next one?
And then start Tara being terrified again.
Start the stress again.
Start the training again.
You know,
you can't slack off,
can't,
can't get injured.
You gotta you know,
it was just,
it was so much of,
it was like so much more stressful than just regular life.
But in a way it made you engage.
I mean,
I think kids that come from a childhood like yours have two options.
You,
it's fight or flight.
You either get into drugs and fucking up and rejecting everything socially or
you can focus hyper focus in on something which in a sense made you show up for
life and made you engage.
Yeah,
it makes you,
it lets you control that thing inside of you too.
You figure out how to discipline because if you don't those crazy wild emotions
like a lot of people that engage in violent crime if violent activities and make
horrible mistakes socially.
A lot of that is this overwhelming response,
this overwhelming energy that you've developed from just being raised in a
terrible environment and my environment was nothing compared to a lot of
people's,
I mean my,
my environment up until I was five was pretty violent with my mom and my dad.
Nobody hit me,
you know,
I was okay.
It was what?
It could have been way worse.
We always had food and then we got to live with my grandfather and my
grandmother when I was five,
so I got to see that my mother was a strong woman and she set a positive
example.
When someone's abusing you,
you don't just take it.
You can now.
Right.
So the first time I ever saw
did you,
and that's huge.
I think one of the most difficult things with domestic abuse is to see that the,
that your mother is not fighting back and you see then you become a victim
yourself.
Yes.
And that you feel like also you,
you're a vulnerable human being at that you need to be protected.
That's the number one thing a parent is doing.
And when you feel like you're not being protected,
your world is fucking chaos.
Well,
no,
not only that,
it was important to me,
I think to see that my mother stood up for herself and that she realized that
this is no way to live life.
And no matter what a person tells you,
if they tell you they love you and they hit you,
this is not love.
You got to get out of there.
And so it made sense that we left.
Like I never felt bad that we left my dad.
I've,
I've felt weird that they weren't together anymore,
but I never felt like my mom did the wrong thing.
I knew she did the right thing.
Really?
Yeah.
It was no doubt about it.
Even at five I knew we had to get away from him.
You know,
that's really weird because most kids,
there's,
you know that that relationship with your parents being together is,
it's life itself.
It is sustenance,
it's food,
it's protection that their units thing together.
So for you to feel otherwise is,
that's very rare.
It was pretty obvious man.
When,
when you see your dad hit your mother yeah.
When you see an [inaudible],
I remember just,
I remember what the Sheetz looked like on the bed.
I remember the,
the layout of the house.
I was five.
I remember the path that I ran to get out of the kitchen when he hit her.
I remember all that Shit.
My mother brought home hamburger and uh,
she knows she went out to get something to for dinner and my dad got upset that
it was just hamburger.
So he slapped her in the face,
just whacked her in the face and she dropped and I ran.
And you know,
I was probably around five,
somewhere between four and five.
I guess,
and it just is it stained my brain,
like I'll never forget it because sometimes if you see a conflict and you walk
in while the conflict is happening,
you don't know what happened.
You just see violence.
You don't know why someone's hitting someone.
That's very confusing.
But when you see it from the beginning,
there was no room for rationalization.
There wasn't like my mother tried to stab him and then he slapped her.
There was nothing.
There was just my mom came home,
she had hamburger,
he hit her,
he's evil.
It was like
immediate.
He's an animal.
All
I could think of as a little kid was,
wow,
my dad's a piece of shit.
You know that all these ideas that you have about every kid wants to think that
his dad is the greatest.
Like his dad,
Superman.
His Dad is the most righteous and the smartest and coolest.
But I knew my dad was BZ shit.
Yeah,
cause my mom was,
my mom was a sweetheart.
She was just,
my mom is because of the fact.
I think that my grandparents screamed at each other all the time,
like the yell constantly.
My mom rejected that whole heartedly.
She never screams.
I don't think I've seen my mom scream in her entire life in the 60 plus years.
I've known her that she's a rather been alive in the 46 that I've known her.
But she also never seen her.
Yeah.
She's,
she's a great mom.
she's a nice person.
She's a kind nice person.
But
well,
they say if you,
if you know,
if it,
no matter how bad your childhood is,
if your mother is strong and you have a connection with her,
you're,
you're going to be okay.
Uh,
it,
I think it certainly is way better than not having that for sure.
But I think that not having a relationship with your father or having a terrible
one can really fuck a guy up.
You know,
I know a lot of men that are grown men that will still complain about the
relationship that they have with their father,
but their father did this and you didn't encourage me.
Did that and there's certain point in time,
it's like you got to let all that shit guy.
Like you got to move past that and it's hard to move past that if that guy is
still in your life.
You know,
I have a friend who was a bad relationship with his dad and you know his dad's
and salting and his dad blames him for his own childhood and they have this
crazy flare ups and then they'll cut them off and won't talk to him and he's
born and then it was dad.
I'll send him a long email apologizing than to let them back in.
Yeah.
And nothing's changing.
The father is staying the same.
So it's really about your,
it's always at your weakest point that you let him back in again.
Yeah.
I mean there was a divorce at an early age and you know,
they would split time between the dad and the mom and
it's hard,
you know,
cause my advice,
it's like cut them off his cancer man.
Fuck them.
Move,
change or change number,
move.
Don't let them know.
Just get that dude out of your life.
You don't need that idiot 60 fucking years old and he's still stupid.
Yeah.
He's still some dumb asshole that ruins everything.
Just move on,
man.
Yeah.
And that hitting is not coming from a place like you said,
you saw your mother did nothing.
And so you realize that,
uh,
anytime somebody is hitting a child or a spouse,
it's their own anger.
Something's happening in their life,
that they're out of control and they're venting it.
It's not like,
especially you're hitting a kid.
Some people will kids,
I love them comics.
Talk about that.
Like when I was a kid,
there was no timeouts.
There was a fucking smack and there was a knock out.
And it was like,
yeah,
and that was really fucked up.
It's no,
don't be nostalgic about child abuse.
It meant that the dad didn't know what the fuck he was doing and he was letting
off steam.
It's effective.
It definitely puts you in line,
but it also ruins you.
Right.
Fucks your head up.
The idea that that's a beneficial thing is so stupid.
Right.
It's never good to hit kids.
Nope.
You know,
but we,
you know,
the nostalgia for shitty parenting,
the way their parents were raised and their pencils,
right?
People got to get past that.
You've got to get past all that.
That's the number one problem with humans today is they're raised poorly.
The human body and mind together as a cohesive unit is like the most complicated
piece of machinery in the world and developing it is free.
Anybody can do it.
There's no one can tell you how to do it.
And it's the most important resource in our entire society is new human beings,
nice human beings and they're all being developed by fucking idiots.
Shit,
heads and idiots who are responsible for a great percentage of the world's
population.
Like as far as like how many they're shitting out.
And there there is,
there is no training,
no training.
Parent parenthood with Kiana raves.
Ray said like,
what was the famous line about like,
uh,
any asshole can,
if you want to get a fishing license,
you have to take a test,
but any asshole can have a kid.
And it's like,
it really is amazing that there is not more and they're starting to see more and
more of that.
I just did this benefit for this amazing place in Cleveland called the,
um,
fuck off.
I'll think of it.
But you day take families in when they're in crisis.
If the mother feels like she's gonna be here,
she's hit her kid.
She doesn't want to hit them again.
They're about to get thrown out because they don't have rent money.
Uh,
they providence house,
they come in and they can,
how's the kids,
you know,
for two,
three months.
It's sort of a buffer before you go into like a homeless shelter and they give
coaching to the parents.
Here's how you deal with it.
When you're freaking out,
you think you're going to hit your kid.
Here's some substance abuse problems.
Here's parenting classes.
And at the same time the kids are being taken care of and they're being given
tools and it's amazing.
I know you're starting to see more and more of these kind of stop gap,
uh,
agencies coming up that can get,
get in there where there's a problem.
And you know,
reformat the hard drive so that,
that parents are getting what they should have gotten when they were younger,
which is an instruction manual.
And even as they're older,
it's like the amount of time that we spend doing things that are important,
like,
uh,
food and exercise and making money and having a career.
Those are all important things,
right?
And we spend a tremendous amount of,
of time doing those.
But managing your mind and understanding how your mind works and understanding
the bad patterns that your brain can get into and giving yourself tools,
whether it's meditation,
whether it's Yoga
self help books,
can be profound.
Sure,
sure.
Without a doubt.
But time and focus on improving the quality of your thinking,
right.
Improving the quality of the way you interact or relationships that you have
with other human beings.
Tom,
spin on that.
It's so,
um,
under emphasize.
Right,
right.
And it should be a core part of what it means to be a part of a civilization.
Yeah.
We should have community groups where we meet together and we all like exchange
ideas and reemphasize the idea that it's important to have community reemphasize
the idea that it's important,
treat each other
well to the kids to treat each other well.
All of this should be passed down.
That those aren't enemies out there in the street.
Those are all your friends,
that we're all in this together.
Right.
In a big problem is that we no longer have communities.
I mean he's talking about Italy and you know,
I just read this piece about these people that live really long in this small
village in Italy.
And it's not just the diet,
it's the fact that there's,
you know,
200 people in the village and every day you walk to your job and you stop along
the way and you talk to,
you know,
Mrs Mark Gotti of what's going on with your husband and,
and there's this interconnection that makes people feel,
and like you said,
you said things get in perspective.
You know,
you,
the balance of your life is there.
And when you lose that and you move to cities,
I mean,
think of,
look at us.
We don't,
we live on the other coast from our family,
you know,
and the people,
I don't know,
the people in my neighborhood and it's just like,
who the fuck am I?
And so it's like you do have to create,
you have to like,
let's go to dinner,
you know,
let's get,
uh,
there's mommy and me groups where,
you know,
Mommy's in their kids.
That was a really great experience for my wife having that.
But you know,
creating what,
what we're lacking now,
which is the groups of people communicating and supporting.
Without a doubt.
It's one of the most important things as a human being to have to be like a lone
wolf.
Every Lone Wolf I've met as a dick just cuts through all dicks.
Like that was always like the thing that everybody wanted.
The guy could just get on his motorcycle,
on fraud across the country by himself.
He didn't need anybody drive off into the sunset,
would not have a hundred friends.
Like,
what's going on?
Why is this guy just hopping on a horse showing up in town shooting everybody
cause he's an asshole.
This fucking lone riders a Dickhead,
right?
Right.
40 years old.
Where's his friends?
The fuck's going on his horses out front.
He sits down orders a shot of whiskey,
flicks a nickel on the bar,
fucks a whore and leaves again.
What an asshole at nickel.
A fucking nickel for a glass of whiskey and you just dumped a hot load and that
horse is going to have a baby.
Why are you riding a horse across the country?
2014 the fuck you friends,
man.
He wouldn't.
He got a flip phone for,
you've got to get in touch with people,
man.
It's a fun thing that we always romanticize the lone wolf,
right?
Those guys are almost always idiots.
It's the Marlboro man.
Look at him smoking.
Those guys all died.
Every one of those diet guys in the ads died of lung cancer and they died of bad
way.
It's okay.
Is it?
It's a way of saying stay away from me.
I'm blowing a fucking stinky cloud around my face.
My breath is shit,
my teeth are brown.
Tell smokes two packs a day.
So that's unbelievable.
Two pracs.
Yep.
That's a lot.
Standups probably close.
My Dad smoked three and a half packs a day,
drop dead at 51 of a heart attack from it.
Boom.
Wow.
Three and a half packs a day and a half pack.
He used to get up in the morning.
That's like one every seven minutes or something isn't it?
Hey that.
Yeah,
that's what I figured out.
It's about five,
seven medicine.
He would light a cigarette and and smoke it on the edge of his bed.
Throw it in the toilet.
Because I was,
I would always remember I'd any,
wouldn't flush it.
I come down and there would be yellow water and there would be a cigarette.
Just you know,
floating in that.
Then he would light another one.
He'd put it on the basin of the shower,
get in the shower halfway through,
lean out,
take a couple of drags a cigarette.
Yeah.
And he was in radio.
He would just sit there and just when you were too.
Yeah.
Yup.
And I had asthma as a kid.
My mother smoked a pack a day and this is New York.
Our windows are closed most of the year cause it's cold and they would just
chain smoke driving in the car.
And Jane Smoking?
Yes.
You in the right,
right.
Oh amazing.
You don't smoke.
I did smoke for,
you know,
typical teenager,
early twenties and then I had asthma.
It would give me fucking asthma.
That's crazy that they would like leave you in the house
with all their smoke.
Right.
There's no way it gets out.
It's just you would smoke.
You were smoking when you were going to add,
how do you recognize it or not?
You were a smoker.
Right?
Wow.
And I remember we used to have to change the carpets and the and the couch every
once in a while because they would,
it would stink from all the smoke being,
oh my God,
mom's a chain smoker,
dad's a chain smoker and the kids are just suffering and they don't even care.
Right.
They're not even paying attention to the fact that blowing smoke on their
babies.
Right.
Taking the kid,
taking the kids to the doctor's office once a week to get shots for his asthma.
No connection there whatsoever.
Yeah,
it was nuts.
It makes me sad.
That's why I tried to watch mad men,
but I get so bummed out with all the smoking.
It starts to really bother me.
Wow.
Derek,
what a fucking amazing trick they pulled on the American people or people in
general,
get them to poison themselves.
Make it acceptable to not just poison themselves,
but poison themselves in a way where your babies get exposed.
Your ignorance.
We didn't know it was bad for you.
A fucking lit flame that you're inhaling.
Get the fuck out of here.
Are you smoking?
Kools you didn't know it was bad for you.
My mommy smoke.
Kools she black.
No,
no Italian though.
Uh,
Santa Maria.
Is it?
Talk about marketing.
Look at how many black people smoke.
Kools white people.
It's like you can pick a race and I can tell you what fucking cigarettes they
smoke.
Tying smoke Kools seven days.
Yeah.
My mom smoked crack days.
You lived in the city though,
right?
Newark?
Yeah.
That's why she smoked.
Cools.
That was probably a lot of people around.
You smell smoking
well,
it was a confused neighborhood man there when it was,
uh,
one of my grandparents,
my grandparents moved to this place called North Ninth Street in Newark,
New Jersey,
which in this day is more of like a South American or maybe Dominican's and
some,
some other,
uh,
Spanish speaking people.
But when they first moved there,
it was all Italians.
It was an Italian neighborhood.
The Italian immigrants would come in and my grandparents came in from Italy when
they were children,
their grandparents were full grown.
They took their family,
brought them over to Italy.
So both my grandmother and my grandfather were both born in Italy on my mom's
side.
And so they,
they come over to America.
They all moved to this North Ninth Street neighborhood.
They have a family.
And then when my mom and her brothers were young,
they did a thing called blockbusting.
And that's how they got people to move out of neighborhoods.
Real estate people to generate sales would sell a house to,
right,
right.
And then tell everybody,
hey,
the blacks were moving in,
you guys are going to go down you bell south.
So people would sell in a panic.
But my grandfather was like,
I like black people,
get the fuck off my lawn.
Me some cool.
He kicked him out of there.
My grandfather was like,
that's one thing you know you think of old Italian people's being racist.
My grandfather,
I never saw him ever say a racist thing in his life.
His next door neighbor was black.
There's a black family that lived next door.
Like all throughout my childhood.
This kid,
I would play with them,
I would go next door and play with them.
Was this a,
this black family that moved next door and my grandfather and the,
the guy who lived next door,
they would hang over the fence.
You know,
the guys would like sit on the fence.
They were like,
hang her arms over.
So what's going on with Bobby?
How's he doing now?
Bobby's,
it's cool.
Like it was like they would have this bond.
So like racism to me was completely alien,
but because of my grandparents,
but it's actually very empowering for a child to see their parents interact with
different races because you,
you're getting different that that child is seeing other messages out there that
are racist.
And when you see your parent,
you know,
have a relationship,
it really makes you feel like,
wow,
life isn't bad.
It can be,
you know,
this is,
well,
there was a really poor neighborhood.
But,
um,
my grandparents neighbors were very friendly and they got along great.
But the neighbor on the other side was a crack dealer.
And,
uh,
he was a kid when I met him.
It was just a young kid.
We were around the same age blanket.
Yeah.
And then when I went back,
um,
they didn't live there anymore or do they live?
They did live there.
But anyway,
the kid next door was selling crack.
This was,
and I was like,
maybe in my twenties,
I came back to stay with my grandfather for awhile when I first moved from
Boston,
New York.
And,
uh,
they battering rammed his door and he fucking broke his door down like right
when I was moving in.
And they,
they,
they broke this kid's door down to rest of me at an Audi in the driveway that,
so the neighborhood changed radically and went from being all Italian to a black
and a few Italians that held out like my grandparents.
And then there was like this bakery that was down the corner that had been there
since like 1920,
that was all Italian.
And then,
you know,
my grandparents would walk to the bakery and the bread every day,
but then they sold the black folks sold and left two and then it became like
Dominicans and Puerto Rican.
Right.
It's like sort of like,
like in a lot of countries you have waves of immigrants.
Yeah.
The Dominican's have been the,
they're,
they're not the most recent way of I now you've got eastern Europeans coming in,
but I mean the,
the,
when the Dominicans came in,
man,
they fucking came in.
You talk about like,
I was born in the,
and this neighborhood called
Throggs neck.
I live at a child.
Was like five.
And that's where my mom grew up.
That's where my,
my wife's mother went to the same high school as my mom.
Wow.
Saint Helen is in the Bronx and uh,
it was a pocket of solidly Irish people and Italians.
And to this day you walk through that neighborhood,
it's all Irish,
Italian,
still still some Dominican's.
Wow.
They got in there,
but it's like,
it didn't change.
It's still got like you go to the meat store,
you go to the,
uh,
you know the cheese shop.
It's all,
you know,
there's ice cream parlor from way back when it's all,
it's like fucking Europe.
That's what the W W W for people don't understand.
Like,
like spike Lee was trying to fight against gentrification in Brooklyn.
You know,
he was talking about how it's so crazy that you know,
they,
all these people move in and then they make these rent's expensive and the
people that have lived there for years and years can't live there anymore.
Right.
And He,
the way he's talking about like,
people are like,
well,
do you know,
do you live there anymore?
And he was like,
well,
I can't live there anymore cause I did.
But people get ringing my doorbell.
You know,
they knew where spike Lee lived,
lived in a normal place.
They just ring his door.
But y'all spike.
And he goes,
my wife made me leave.
Like you could tell when he was saying that it was true.
He goes,
but I still have love for that city.
But that cities like those cities,
especially like Brooklyn,
there's areas of Brooklyn that are just,
they're just moving people in and it becomes trendy to live in this once quaint
neighborhood.
And then the real estate just doubles.
Yeah.
Changes Venice where I,
I've got a house in Venice last 13 years and we,
when we moved in,
it was like 10 years earlier was the number one homicide place in the country.
It was all gangs.
And then they got the gangs out and they're cute houses.
Not Big,
but you know,
craftsman style houses,
but all walk streets.
So you gotta,
you know,
a sidewalk with house on either side.
But Calvin used to live there.
Right,
exactly.
So,
uh,
you know,
that neighbor is fucking beautiful,
great neighborhood.
And so,
uh,
all of a sudden though,
it's getting to the point where my buddy was renting an apartment three doors
down from me.
This is the guy who I lived next door to.
And when I was talking about neighbors,
I was friends with a Mulberry Street.
This guy,
gay guy,
I became really good friends with,
he moved out to Venice.
So we bought,
we bought a house three doors down from him,
one of my best friends,
he's got to move their fucking tearing down his apartment and they're putting up
like luxury,
uh,
duplexes.
And he's like,
I can't afford to live in this neighborhood.
He doesn't make any money.
So he's like,
I gotta move back to New York.
Wow.
Callan sold his place just when they turned the neighborhood turned because
Google opened up an office there.
So as Google was setting up shop there,
a bunch of people started looking for places to buy,
like executives and stuff and count and a really cool place and he made this
insane profit.
He's like,
just when I put it on the market,
that's when the property values went crazy.
But it's still going up.
I get,
I get offers all the time.
I get unsolicited offers on my house for like two and a half times what I paid
for the house.
But I guess hanging onto it good.
Because it's got,
it's got,
I think we're going to retire in that house some day,
but,
but the front,
it's,
we
out grew at it.
Say,
you know,
there's a front house with like,
um,
you know,
a big bonus house in the back,
but it's got a two bedroom apartment above that and a studio next to it.
So we rent out three units in the house and that's going to put the kids through
college and then we're going to live in it when,
uh,
when they move out.
That's a good idea.
That's a good move.
That community,
like I have an affinity to be for beach communities.
Yeah.
I think there's something about living near the ocean that has this sort of
unspoken mellowness to it that just comes from being next to something so
humbling.
Right.
Oh,
well you can't like thank you,
really important.
Or you're the shit or life was so powerful and meaningful when you're standing
next to the most insane body of water.
Known demand
surfers really seem to be the happiest,
most balanced people you meet.
Their priorities just are different.
They get up early in the morning,
go ride some waves and then nothing else seems to matter.
Oh,
I don't get it.
I mean I,
I do get it,
but I'm scared of sharks.
So surfing.
Yeah.
Surfing's a,
it's a pretty intense thing.
I mean,
I've done it.
My daughter's really into it,
so we go a lot.
Yeah.
We,
last summer we would go like three,
four days a week and big fucking eight foot long board and she's tiny and she
gets on that.
She's got great balance and she gets on it and she just jumps up and rides these
waves,
not,
she doesn't ride the big waves.
Like once they crash,
there's like that giant foam.
She kind of rides that.
Oh Wow.
But,
but actually riding a wave as a whole different story.
I've tried a bunch of times and man,
if the front tip of the board goes down,
you just flip and that Shit's flying over your head.
It's like fuck this.
Oh,
where do you guys go?
Venice beach.
No Shit.
Straight out.
Everybody thinks Venice beaches.
It's got this reputation for being dirty and whatever.
That was years ago.
There's this thing called heal the bay that there's a lot of big celebrities
like Julia Louise Dreyfus and uh,
uh,
what's her name?
It was married to um,
Swarts and Egger.
Um,
Maria Shriver dare Dave been all over the shit for 20 years.
And the beaches they have a rating on if you've got to heal the bay.com,
it gives a rating on the cleanliness of the water from Malibu all the way down
to Marina del Rey and Venice beach a plus all the time.
Wow,
that's amazing.
I didn't know that.
I had no idea.
Does there ever any assholes surfing?
Cause that's one thing I have friends.
There is,
let's say there's a lot of arguments,
right?
It's very,
um,
because it's trendy.
You got all these guys that these newbies come in and they get their board at
Costco and they don't know what the fuck they're doing.
And it's all about when you drop into the wave,
you know,
if another guy's already on the wave,
you can't get in his path or he's going to get fucking pissed and yeah.
There's like fist fights out there.
Yeah.
Some I have,
um,
a friend,
uh,
who would go surfing there and always tell some new story about almost getting
into a fight.
Oh,
Teddy Eft,
but Eddie F oh yeah.
Right.
He tells a story about almost getting into a fight everywhere he goes,
it will be the fucking supermarket and I'm telling this guy,
fuck you and fuck your mother.
How about that?
Right.
I know it's
true.
He's always got a story about almost getting in a fight.
Yeah.
I'm like,
at certain point in time it might be you.
Yeah.
What's the common denominator here?
A little wired little wire it up.
Yeah.
Fucking tense young man.
All right.
That's a dangerous way to go through life,
man.
I realized there's Times where I'm fucking,
I'm on my edge so hard that I'm scared because I know if somebody cuts me off or
whatever,
yeah,
I'm going to go and I get a really fucking breathe.
Then I get an Irish temper.
I got a power of now at down.
Yeah,
and you have some nice guy too.
It doesn't make any sense.
Nobody.
He'll tell these stories and you're like,
wait,
what?
Going on.
My interaction with them,
which has never been anything other than pleasant and fun like I love hanging
out with that guy.
I love having them on podcasts.
Doing comedy shows with them has always been fun.
He's a fun guy,
but they'll tell you these stories about told me the story about a bar.
We told some woman,
you're the worst fucking human being I've ever met in my life.
I hope you die in a fire.
And he's saying all these horrible things in the fucking bars.
Patrons are chasing them out into the parking lot and like,
what are you doing Eddie?
What is that?
What's causing this?
Right.
I like when you see comics that are like otherwise Nice,
calm,
cheery comics and they can't handle hecklers and they just go to a fucking like
remember Frank Santa Rally.
Oh yeah.
Great comic.
One of the most underrated comics.
Talk about guys that didn't leave Boston that were phenomenal.
I mean the timing on that guy in his writing and everything.
But he did wait for a while,
didn't he?
Didn't he?
He wasn't surprised was the bartender,
but he didn't leave beat him up.
Remember?
Yeah.
I beat the shit out of him.
But he would snap man,
when he got heckled,
that dude got dark and he couldn't get back into his act because when you show
the crowd that side of you,
you can't suddenly start though.
And you ever noticed pigeons or Nah,
you just fucking almost killed somebody pray.
Oh yeah.
There was some dudes,
it just didn't,
not only could they not handle it,
they just,
they're,
they're cool with just evaporate right before your eyes.
Right.
You'd see what's going on really in the,
and then you couldn't,
you couldn't take their acts seriously anymore.
Yeah.
Cause it was seem like you.
So that's not really you.
I want to see that other guy.
That guy was compelling.
Make him funny.
I mean that's why people loved Hicks and Kennison cause they took the two things
and brought them together.
Well they figured out a way.
Right.
Do you remember the,
the Hicks thing where he's,
some woman's heckling them in Chicago and he starts calling screaming at her,
calling her,
look at me.
I'm a con.
It's fucking great.
I have carte blanche cause I've got a pussy.
It's hilarious.
But screaming,
screaming as some woman who's heckling.
It's a good release man,
man.
Anytime it happens I just make sure I tee it up.
If there's,
if some some bitch heckling me or some guy,
I just make sure keep giving them rope,
keep giving them rope.
So the crowd starts looking at you like,
hey,
you gotta do it now.
And then you can take all the anger
that's pent up inside of you and unleash it on this mother.
Yeah,
that is the key,
isn't it?
You've got to play the bow.
You gotta like pull the bow back all the way before you shoot the Arrow.
Yeah,
if you just pull it back a little bit and shoot the air like,
oh,
what'd you do?
And they were like,
he's one of us.
Turn this up
it so
pull it out.
So see you here.
Yeah,
buddy.
Thank you man.
Be My little echo.
You sucks.
Goes
yes,
my,
my mother and uh,
you fucking car.
Get the fuck Outta here right now.
Get Out.
Fuck you.
You idiot.
You're everything that America should be flushed down the toilet.
You fucking car.
Fuck you.
Get Out.
You fucking profit.
Take her out.
Take her fucking out.
Go see fucking Madonna.
You fucking idiot.
Yeah.
The,
you can yell at a comedian.
He's not my drunk.
I can do it.
I get yelled at Barnard and I both don't get it yet cause I got it
fucking Scholl.
Well that's some real anger,
man.
Did you see him run across the stage and it was beautiful and some real anger?
No.
Y'All ready to see that?
That was ahead of its time.
Nobody did that.
Nobody.
Nobody did that back then,
but people started doing that.
After that,
I started doing that.
I started going after after hecklers in the audience in a better way.
After I saw things like that,
you realize that you,
you can,
it doesn't have to be nice.
Like you can get away with some shit,
right?
Yeah.
As long as it's got enough of a buildup.
As long as the audience is on your side.
Yeah.
Give it context.
Put a black hat on that motherfucker and then pull out your revolver and just
starts here.
And the thing is,
is like you,
you have to gauge any,
any,
in any given interaction to the audience.
You gauge who the,
you got to fucking figure it out fast.
Are they going to,
are they going to charge the stage?
Are they gonna keep heckling or are they going to leave you?
Gotta you gotta tear it out.
Stitches.
Stitches in Boston's you got into like physically attacked.
You got in a wrestling match with some dudes wrestling match.
No,
the guy came up.
He,
uh,
he took a swing at me.
I ducked,
I hit him in the head with a microphone.
And then he was from the Israeli army.
He was a cab driver who was there.
His name is [inaudible].
I still remember that because I said,
you know,
that's the name of the village,
idiot and Woody Allen's movie,
love and death.
Right.
And he came up
and he got me in a fucking headlock and that dude was spinning me around the
stage and knocking down tables.
I couldn't get out.
And the ballot,
you know,
stitches.
It's,
it's the stage is surrounded by the crowd.
So of course everybody stands out cause they want to see the fight and the
bouncers can't get up there.
And so it just fucking went on for a while.
And then finally the bouncers came up and two of my buddies,
you know,
Mike Gibbons and they're at the bar and they're trying to get up there.
They can't get out there.
And,
uh,
the got 'em out and then the owner,
do you remember that guy?
I'm hairy little dude,
Harry.
He goes,
uh,
Susie.
Yeah,
Harry could afford it.
He goes,
uh,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fits you.
Gotta you got 10 minutes left and they reintroduced me.
I'm like,
what?
Oh,
you got fucking done.
So I go up and I get on stage and I got a standing ovation because they would,
they rather see Boston.
They rather see a fight.
Then his comedy show,
my first standing ovation of my life and then I went to the chiropractor.
My neck was fucked.
Do you remember what you said to the audience?
Yeah,
I walked up and uh,
and they clapped and once they calmed down,
I looked around and I go,
all right,
who's next?
Yeah,
I remember that.
I wasn't there for it.
I remember you telling me that and everybody else was talking about how you said
that too.
And I was like,
that's hilarious.
Well actually Brian Frazier gave me the line.
He was,
he was laying on it.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Brian Frazier,
he was fucking funny.
Tiny yet.
He was a guy that I had to tell to stop wearing tee shirts on stage.
He was a rough number.
How big he was when he was doing bodybuilding.
Yeah.
And he,
he was like ridiculously huge.
I mean,
just giant,
giant arms.
And he would go on stage and he was wearing like a golf shirt on like a collared
golf shirt.
I told him,
I go,
dude,
you can't wear that.
I'll go,
it's too distracting.
Oh,
everybody's doing is looking at the size of your fucking arms.
You're,
you're intimidated and you're angry and you're like,
what is this?
Like that's his act that he's getting all fired up.
Big giant fucking arms.
Right.
He a almost attacked a club owner in Vermont with me.
I took him up there to Vermont,
we did a Gig together and Brian had sore throat and,
um,
he was,
uh,
he had a really good set,
but he was,
he was real conscientious,
you know,
and so he was apologizing to the,
the owner that his throat sore,
you know,
like,
he was just,
you know,
just being a good guy,
uh,
you know,
feeling bad that he didn't,
do the performance that he wanted because his throat throws a little sore.
Meanwhile,
I was still great.
And so the club owner was like relaxed.
Like,
why are you,
you know,
what do ya,
what are you apologizing about?
Why he complained about it?
What are you Jewish,
he didn't look Jewish because Brian looked like he was Irish.
He was Jewish,
he was big giant guy with blonde curly hair.
Right.
So you didn't expect him to be Jewish,
but he was Jewish and he was really sensitive to antisemitic stuff.
So this guy calls him,
you know,
what are you chewing?
And he goes,
I am fucking Jewish.
And he got really angry and you know,
he's fucking huge.
He's screaming at the guy with his course voice,
I'm a fucking Joe,
I am a fucking jail.
And it's like whoa.
He,
I saw him snap a few times.
You use,
he was wired tight.
He was,
yeah,
he had a hair trigger.
I didn't know what was gonna happen cause he was like leaning over this guy's
desk and the guy was just,
you know,
fat millage dude wasn't shape at all.
And Brian was my friend and I had to figure out like,
what would I do if the shit went down cause he was way stronger than me.
Frazier was like way bigger than me.
Right.
So I was like,
this kid get crazy.
I know what the fuck am I to deal,
but talk them out of it.
I'm not going to hit him.
You know,
he's my friend.
I hope he doesn't kill this guy.
Jesus.
If he does kill this guy,
have,
what does that make me in a complex?
Like how's that work?
I got to drive home after that.
It makes me in a cop taking a fugitive across state lines.
Right.
He didn't do anything.
I mean,
boys scared the fuck out of that dude.
Like I never expected him to be Jewish and he also never expected him to be
fucking crazy either.
So when he's,
you know,
angry,
not just anti,
you know,
not just angry about the antisemitism,
but like violently angry.
Yeah.
Plus he was,
he was frustrated.
He hadn't had a good set,
so he's already pissed.
That was fine.
That was what the guy was sad about it.
He was just being conscientious.
Think right.
It wasn't a bad set at all.
You know,
it wasn't a set that you would ever be in.
There's Brian.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
When I was a little kid,
I was so impatient.
I would actually just take my slinky and brought down the stairs.
So you would never imagine that guy's Jewish
people.
That's pretty much my hobby now bothering people.
I like to go to laundromats and hide in the washing machines.
Someone opens up the lead to put their clothes and I pop out and go,
I'm using this one.
Huh?
He's a funny dude.
He was a writer.
Yeah,
he wrote on some shows.
I think I wrote with him on one show,
but I'm never popped as a writer.
I Dunno why,
but he's doing some other shit now.
It's like,
I don't know if he's doing art or a,
he got into something else as well as comedy.
Yeah.
He was always a dude with a lot of other interests.
This guy,
my next door neighbor in Venice,
this guy,
uh,
Danny,
he became,
he act or one of these dudes that I'm telling you for the last 12 years,
he's had development deals Orlando at a pilot every single year.
Okay,
good looking guy.
Good Act or funny.
Not a stand up,
but just made for sitcoms and uh,
and yet hasn't really been in a show that's been on the air really at all.
I was on one show that was on for like four or five episodes and that's it in 12
years,
but the checks fucking roll in it.
So he got somehow involved,
but he grew up in La and he knows a lot of famous people.
I mean he went to school with like,
you know Jared Leto Leto or Lettow,
I'm not sure,
but he,
he's like his best friend.
And anyway,
so you know that artist Banksy,
he became the rep for banks,
these work in Los Angeles.
So he goes off and he is selling Banksy art too.
You know,
he's got a couple dozen big celebrities that buy art and you know,
the commissions on these million dollar pieces are fucking huge.
And then he started getting into other,
other artists,
other galleries approached him.
He came over my house last night.
He's telling me all this shit and he is moving expensive art constantly.
And he's like,
t he just landed another pilot.
He's like,
Dad,
I hope it goes,
but it doesn't mean what it is too.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's smart to diversify man.
How,
especially in that business,
AL,
yeah.
Business of auditioning and trying to get someone to accept you to put you on a
show.
Right?
There's a reason why the culture of La so fucking Wacky,
and it's not just because actors are shallow,
it's not just because the,
the pursuit of fame is sort of a frivolous and ultimately like it's a pretty,
pretty selfish pursuit.
Right?
It's not just that
by nature it's promoting yourself.
Yeah.
And that that just encourages douchey behavior.
But then you factor in the fact they're always trying to get accepted.
So you take people who are most likely damaged,
which is why they want all this additional acceptance in the first place.
Like why do they want to be considered to be set exceptional or f or a,
why do they want to be the one person everybody looks at when they walked on the
street?
Usually it's because they weren't,
they didn't feel like they were worth anything when they were young.
Right?
Right.
So then you take that and you have,
I'm auditioning for things all the time and constantly being rejected and seeing
other people get things and realizing that networking is important,
so you've got to develop your own personality so that you,
you,
you fit into the establishment,
Eric.
Yeah.
You want to be what they want and you're not longer trying to be yourself.
You have to
aspire to whatever,
whatever political ideal that they have,
you have to adopt those.
Like how many people are these buttoned down liberals in Hollywood that have
literally never thought about any of the issues.
Right.
And so you have discussions with them,
whether it's a discussion about affirmative action with this discussion about
global warming,
whether whatever it is,
you find out how woefully uninformed they are
and how awkward it is when you hold opinions that are different than theirs
because it's really about let's all sit together and pile on the right side of
an issue together.
If you're not on that side,
it gets fucking weird.
Yeah.
It's like that conversation we had about the owner of the clippers.
Try having that shit in the,
in the lobby of the Improv with a bunch of,
you know,
comics that are showcasing for something.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
You can't,
you can't,
they're all panicking.
Yeah.
It really is.
It's not that the people are shallow,
it's bringing the shallow part out of people and it really is,
if you put yourself like you moving to Colorado,
are you moving outside of La the way you did?
It's a choice to try to get your balance back and try to,
you know,
work against what you ultimately have to feed into to some degree.
But if you live in like people that live in Hollywood,
I just think you don't have a fucking,
yeah,
you're swarmed.
You're,
you're in the cult of personality right in the middle of the wave.
[inaudible] trying to keep your head above.
You go to Ralph's to get groceries,
you're going to bump into another actor or an agent and you're just always
thinking about what am I wearing?
And Yeah,
fuck that.
Well,
they're also just not that fascinating.
Now people themselves like the pursuit of fame,
the ultimate pursuit of fame,
like what we were talking about,
the Kim Kardashian thing is one of the best examples because it's the ultimate
pursuit of frame with no context behind it.
There's no substance,
there's no literature,
there's no,
there's no art.
There's just a person,
just a person that's not exceptional getting attention and that being the
ultimate in shallow pursuits.
If you're surrounded by all that,
it becomes a competitive thing where other people want to be a part of it.
They want to do the same thing.
They want to get in there too,
and if you are in that,
you step into that soup,
you're like,
ah,
it's a lot of noise.
Nothing's happening here,
and the noise is contagious.
It's contagious.
Suddenly you find your values changing because the way you get to be Kim
Kardashian is you make alignments with people like Paris Hilton.
I mean that's how she got there.
They were best friends,
and then you start to realize as a person in Hollywood,
every conversation you have,
every relationship there is a power structure and somebody's trying to get
something from the other person and you start to think that way.
When you're around that all the time,
you can't.
You can't.
Especially if,
here's what the payoff of fame is.
Every person that's coming to you,
you know that they have an agenda.
That's your life.
That's a lot of people's lives for sure.
Especially if you're like,
say if you're an actor and you're in movies all the time to imagine if you are
Brad Pitt and you,
you'd go and anything you're doing,
you were running into people in various walks of life.
How many of them are bringing you scripts?
How many of them have an idea?
How many of them want you to set up a meeting for them?
How many of them want to know if you know you have any pull on your next film,
like getting my brother's an actor and he's really trying hard to get his first
big break.
Maybe you can put them on one of your movies.
I mean,
that shit must be,
or are they just want a little piece of you.
They want to be able to take a picture.
They want a story that they're going to tell the rest of their life about when
they met Brad Pitt.
It's not going to be like you meeting somebody on neutral ground and saying,
Hey,
what's up?
Who are you?
You know,
get to know each other.
No,
it's,
this is Brad Pitt.
I'm gonna grab a little piece of Brad Pitt that I'm going to carry with me and
I'm going to shit.
And you want,
and that's why people love to say,
Brad Pitt's an asshole.
Everyone's an asshole because that's a better story.
Then I walked up to him on the street.
He was busy.
He took a second out,
he had things to do and so we moved on.
It's much,
it's a much better story to go and,
Oh,
and he's fullest was fucking asshole.
He ignored me.
And you know,
so everybody's collecting those stories.
Well,
there's always weak,
weak people that you're going to run into the,
for whatever reason,
choose to say that you're an Asshole,
right?
Because of their interaction.
You,
yeah.
If you're a guy like a Brad Pitt and you're,
you know,
you have some weird magic trick where you,
everywhere you go,
everybody wants to pay attention to you.
And as a another person who values being themselves,
who thinks of themselves highly and wonders why,
you know,
it was fucking Brad Pitt,
what's so special about him?
You know,
and then you meet him,
you're like,
Hey Brad,
how you doing?
He's like,
Hey Dick,
you fucking dick thinks he's too good for us.
Fucking Dick.
I mean,
when you're concentrating on him,
why are you concentrating on him?
Cause he's got some weird magic trick and you,
you think that magic trick should be yours,
right?
You're the one being a dick because you're walking,
he's having dinner with his family and you're walking up to his table.
That's a dick move.
That is a dick move.
And that's the one time I never take pictures of people.
I've had people do that.
The come to the table to take pictures,
move.
It's like,
come on man.
Right?
It's so Douchey,
right?
But people don't realize it.
They feel like anybody they run into,
they run into someone famous.
They can't imagine that that person gets run into people all day long.
They think,
hey,
this is my chance to big moment.
Kim Kardashian,
O m g Kim,
you're one of my personal heroes.
Can I take a photo with you?
As you say,
yeah,
you're my role model.
I'm a big fan.
I love your shoes.
Feed them whatever shit you think is going to make a connection with them.
But you,
you're really good after shows at meeting people,
you look them in the eye,
you shake their hand,
you take the picture,
but yet you're able to fucking keep them moving.
That's,
that's really hard because people want to latch on.
Can I take a picture?
Uh,
give the wife to fucking cameras.
She doesn't know how to work and all sudden you,
I see your lines.
It shows you have 50 or a hundred people waiting to say hi to you.
And it's hard to keep those people moving.
No.
Sometimes it is.
The real problem is when people aren't even thinking about the other people
behind them in line,
like there's a bunch of other people waiting and they want to tell you some
story.
Like you can't tell me that story,
man.
Right.
So many people are.
Then some people wait till the very end.
They want to be last in the line and then they want to tell you this long stupid
thing describing some project that I'm not going to invest in.
I'm like,
dude,
no,
I'm not,
not interested.
I'm busy.
Well,
listen,
you can make a lot of money to stop.
Stop.
I'm not doing it.
I'm not investing in some fucking,
it's not happening.
So what do you do if somebody,
half way through the lines starts digging into a long story?
Tell there's a lot of people behind them.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
you can't,
you're rude.
You're being rude to these other folks.
Really rude.
It's not going to happen.
Yeah.
The,
it's the,
it's the people that do it.
The people that really want to tell you the long dumb story,
like invest in my idea,
my,
my company,
my thing.
They're always there.
They're always like sort of like so bullheaded and,
and like really obsessed with getting someone else involved and whatever idea
that they're pitching,
but they're not thinking about it.
They're not thinking about the other people on the line and I'm thinking about
you or your attention span.
They're thinking about their idea.
Here's my shot.
Let me get it out there.
You know,
I was talking the other day about this guy who gave me his fucking movie script.
He wanted me to read his movie script and then get it to producers.
You know,
I really need a break and you've got your break and I'll go,
look dude,
I'm not even in the movie business.
You can't,
you can't just give scripts and tell me,
read them.
I don't know you.
Yeah,
I don't know the script.
You're asking for an hour and a half out of a person's time.
Yeah,
look bro,
it's really good.
It's really good.
Okay.
Then ticket to a fucking book agent.
That's easy for you to say,
okay,
it's easy for me you to say you helped me.
Yeah.
And then also I get people that send me,
uh,
pitches for sitcoms or whatever and I always,
I don't read it.
I as soon as I see that's what it is,
I reply and I go,
look,
I'm in the writer's guild.
I am pitching my own shit.
If this is,
I didn't rate it.
But if it's similar to what I'm doing,
I don't want to be in a position where then you're claiming that it was your
idea.
So I'm very polite,
but I say it's just as a rule,
I can't read people's pitches.
Yeah.
I've talked to people who say they're suing someone cause they sent them
something and then this person had an idea that's similar and they start doing
it.
I know they stole my idea.
Well did they solicit that idea?
No,
you just send it to them.
Like what are you doing to sending people ideas?
Right.
Well when you send it through the email,
it's like you patent it.
Like,
okay,
all right.
That ain't the way to do it.
Okay.
And in this weird day and age,
it's there's more distribution methods for ideas than ever before.
And if you have some really cool ideas,
you could put your cool ideas on a website.
You know,
if you want to start writing books,
the best way to start writing is make a blog that people think is popular,
that people liked your ideas and then then sell a book from there.
Make something where people can share it to people for free with other people
for free.
Yeah.
And it's a meritocracy.
I always say this about especially about stand up.
If you're a funny Stan,
I don't want to hear anybody complain that they can't get a break or can't get
seen.
If you are working hard and you're funny,
you will be found because there's money in it.
There's agents and managers and producers and studios that are looking for the
next fucking,
you know,
a name a star.
They,
there is equity in that.
So just focus on your fucking work.
And the same thing with writing.
Like you said,
put it out there.
If it's good,
it will be found
and stand up as an interesting thing for women too because although it's harder
I think to be a woman and to be a standup comic,
I think there's like more subjects that they have a hard time covering that they
have a hard time audience getting the audience to accept them.
Talking about things like having an opinion on politics or having an opinion on
certain social issues that may be,
yeah,
that may be controversial.
Whereas the guy can maybe guys,
other guys will listen to a guy having opinions on those things before they'll
listen to a woman.
But if a girl can be funny,
the,
the possibilities are giant.
Like for a really funny woman,
like doors just opened up like there's so many,
well look at it right now.
You look at Chelsea handler and Whitney and um,
uh,
what's your name on comedy central that has that Amy Schumer?
I mean it is a time when the industry is looking for strong female voices and
they're getting ratings and a,
and once you get it,
you write the book.
You didn't stand up dates,
you get the shell.
I mean,
Whitney at one point at three fucking shows on last,
Kathy Griffin,
this,
the ones that were really Sarah Silverman,
the ones that are really good,
they just become,
you know,
it's,
there's a huge market for a really funny woman.
It's also like their comedy relates to women in a lot of ways that are common is
just not going to just like music,
just like writing.
Like anything else.
Like women have,
a lot of women have a very different sense of humor than men do.
Well,
and also they say that women are the ones that primarily decide when and if
you're going to a comedy show and who you're going to go see,
because think about it,
you're sitting at home on a Friday after work and your wife goes,
what do you want to do?
And I,
oh no,
no.
Well there's this and then you've,
you do what she says.
I think maybe 30% of the people that come see me or women.
That's it.
Yeah,
maybe.
Probably about 30 yeah,
it's mostly dudes.
Yeah.
Nothing you can do about that.
Comedy central show at one of the highest male percentage audiences they've ever
seen.
Well,
that's what the network wants.
75% and they want that.
Yeah.
You are the sought after demographic.
Well,
I think the women is a sought after demographic too.
I mean,
you look at Chelsea handler,
look at,
you know Amy Schumer Shields,
the gay men know they both have huge gay male populations.
That's interesting.
And those guys are great because they have disposable income because majority of
them don't have kids.
Right?
No babies.
And they don't have to impress each other the same way that men have to impress
women.
They're both men.
Right?
You want to fuck?
No,
I was going to ask you if you wanted to fuck.
Let's fuck
both hitting not each other.
They look fucking head budding.
Right,
right,
right.
Hey,
you want to fuck?
Fuck you man.
I was about to ask you.
Oh,
I said at first I was thinking that you read minds.
I wonder if you get to fuck the guy.
If you ask first,
maybe that's,
that's really,
really horrible things.
It's not a horrible thing to say.
The only id,
the only reason why it's a hard,
bold thing to say is because really ultra sensitive progressive's have made such
a big deal out of gay people that you think it's a horrible things.
You think they do rock scissors.
That's probably what they do.
They probably are messed up to see who gets to suck cock first.
Yeah.
Maybe it's like Dick Condom balls.
There's something
run with that idea and it's probably likely,
but you know,
you gotta be real sensitive about even cracking a joke about gay men lest you be
considered homophobic.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's a weird thing,
man.
Just because you make fun of gay people doesn't mean you're homophobic.
Gay people or men or men are hilarious.
We're hilarious in our pursuit to dump loads,
right?
You know,
find people to help us release loads.
Help me please.
And Gay guys are just as Hilarious as we are.
Well,
and the beautiful thing is like with women,
you really got to gauge their mood,
their cycle there.
You know what,
what conversations you've had lately,
don't be disrespectful and treat them like meat.
Men want to be treated,
not treated like meat.
There's no emotions here.
I got to,
I got a sack that needs emptying and you're a human.
Let's do it.
Fuck,
I wish I was gay,
man.
I really do.
They got,
you got options.
Damn.
Especially if you could date a guy who's into sports that just hangs out and
then you just happen to dump loads in each other.
I just,
Scott Kennedy,
so he's joking.
Roundabout.
Yeah.
Scott can bless him.
God bless him.
Rest his soul.
He used to always joke around about it cause he was like a real,
he was a gay guy,
but he was like this real like jockish gay guy.
Really big.
Always were football jersey.
Yeah.
And just gay unabashedly gay as fuck.
And he would let the audience know like quite a few minutes into his is
actually,
if you can find any scar Kennedy Online,
he would let the audience know like you know,
oh well he would wait a while into his act before he ever let him know that he
was gay.
And you,
and then he would say it.
You thought he was kidding at first?
The took a while to sink in.
Yeah,
I saw him in Houston.
I first saw him in Houston.
He was a Houston comic.
Right.
And uh,
he was a part of that wave of really good guys that came out of the laugh stop
in river oaks.
Yes.
Sean rouse.
Yup.
Uh,
John Wesleyan came out of the day.
Matt Kirsh.
Yup.
And there he is.
Look at that.
That guy's gay guy.
Good on you.
Good
to be honest.
Every day at work be like,
yes.
Snickers or three for a dollar,
but your fat ass doesn't need,
do I have a supervisor?
Yeah,
he'll be back in like an hour.
[inaudible]
Tock Tick Tock.
You got to go.
Ah,
I read this in the paper today.
Made me feel really old.
Uh,
the show cops,
the TV show cops has now been on the air for 20 years.
I know,
but you know why it's been on the air for 20 years.
It makes us feel better about our lives.
Don't you think?
Cause I don't care how messed up your family is.
Never quite as screwed up as the people on cops.
You know,
what show was he on his,
obviously some television,
right?
Ferguson,
which by the way,
he just,
uh,
he just quit.
Did you hear about the stories and just sharing to why ran out of funny?
Well,
listen,
real,
there's some real estate out there right now.
You know,
there's some empty time slots,
comedy central and um,
you know,
with Letterman leaving,
I think that's why you retired to go over there.
They may be,
who knows if there's a deal in the works.
I mean they,
they gotta they gotta replace a a bunch of spots now.
Right.
Well he does a lot of stand up.
I know that any probably also makes a lot of money and probably maybe it got to
a certain point in time.
He does.
Once it kicked back.
I don't think he makes shit on that show either.
I know,
I know.
The Kilborne wasn't making shit one time spot.
Yeah.
It's a Letterman owned a piece of property.
It's worldwide pants.
Uh,
they control that hour after letterman's.
What are you saying?
Wasn't making shit like what do you mean?
I'm talking 10 grand a week.
What,
what?
Wait.
Oh,
when the show started out,
remember when Kilborne left?
They had auditions.
Remember they rotated people in.
They had like five,
six people coming.
Jeff Ross did a week.
Um,
Mike Lee Black did a week and Ferguson did a week and it was like five of them
and then they chose the host based on,
and I happen
to have,
I had access to what those people were being paid for that week.
And the understanding was that's what you're going to make for the series.
And the money was like 10 grand a week.
There had been some sort of a renegotiation,
well,
I'm sure I definitely has gone up,
but when you start at that pay scale and you know,
the Ray,
I don't know what his ratings were,
but um,
you know,
you look at these,
I mean,
what was the Letterman make in a year?
20 million?
I Dunno.
I've never paid attention.
Yeah.
But I bet it was a lot more than 10 grand a week.
All right.
Holy Shit.
So I think he was anytime a guys touring on the weekends while he's got his own
nationally syndicated nightly shell things are a little light.
Why doesn't he like live in New York also?
And like fly in right before the show every day and then fly backwards.
He doesn't want,
I heard something isn't just don't speculate.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then he had some books that did extremely well.
Really well.
He's huge.
And uh,
you know,
the United Kingdom.
Oh,
is he?
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
he started out.
He was big over there as a comic.
Yeah.
It's a good comic.
That's interesting,
man.
I think he's gotten better.
I think he was,
you know,
a lot of these British comics have a hard time translating to American crowds.
I think he made the adjustment over the last few years.
I've,
I've done gigs like right after he was there.
He's done like some of the same theaters that I've done and they stay here,
comes in,
just leaves.
Does this show and bolts is in right before lands?
Private jet takes off afterwards.
Would I do if I was wearing,
you know,
how much,
how hard is doing daily fucking shell.
And then on the weekend you're flying out.
I'd be in and out.
You got,
I mean,
guys get to sleep.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
It's interesting because those,
I think those shows,
those nightly talk shows the way in the format they're currently stuck in.
I think that's like,
it's like old movies.
It's like watching like a silent movie,
right?
It's like why would anybody want to come on and talk for five minutes?
We'll be right back and pray that the band plays you out.
Why is there a band play?
What the fuck is going on?
What am I,
you're just keeping my attention.
It's got pants,
Dota and the band and the cuts to tide is the best thing I've ever had at
getting the shit stains out of my diaper.
I Shit my pants.
I know.
I was thinking about that this morning.
I was thinking about Kimmel and about his great fucking guy and he's a friend of
mine and I think about what he puts himself through on a weekly basis.
You got to get there in the morning,
starting from scratch.
You're going to do a show in eight hours.
That's going to be an hour long packed with jokes,
topics,
opinions,
interviews,
uh,
taped pieces.
You've got to shoot during the day approving stuff.
You got network notes you've got,
I mean it goes on and on every day,
week after week.
Why?
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
I mean it's one thing.
You're doing a podcast.
This is with very little prep with good support and the expectation that you
know what you're going to do is free and loose and honest.
That is so formulated.
It's very formulated,
very time intensive,
requires a lot of PR,
a lot of people to book things and schedule things.
You've got to get the network behind everything.
You have to have commercials,
you have to have promotion,
you have to have support.
Who's on before you?
What's your lead in?
You know a,
well if this guy does Kimmel,
they won't let them do Fallon and then you've got to deal with,
Paul was doing radio interviews around the country every day to promote the
shell.
I mean I used to think that was the dream that I,
that was the job I wanted,
but I think I'd only want it for like a year.
I think that you could do it online.
You can do almost the exact same thing.
If you look at some of the lineups that you see,
like even on Letterman,
you see some of the people that are on Letterman,
you're like,
hmm,
how's that any different than a podcast?
It's really not.
I mean,
occasionally they,
they get like u two or something like that.
Right.
You know,
and you can't get that.
I think you probably would be really hard to get you to the play on your
podcast,
but it might happen.
And lab in a year from now.
I mean,
look,
we have Everlast plays on the podcast.
How's it pains?
One of my all time favorite rap bands that have done the last Everlast spin on a
bunch of times,
but he plays,
he plays acoustic songs on here all the time.
So,
you know,
we've had,
we've had a lot of Dave Nevara interesting people.
Hey,
you and Dave had like a little few.
Danny became buddies.
Yeah,
I was talking shit.
Well,
I did the porn awards and I hosted the porn awards.
Uh,
mostly it was just a dream of my mothers.
And,
uh,
and so I went off and I was in Africa with my family.
We were in South Africa on vacation for like three weeks and they were staying
another week.
And I had to go home to go.
I flew directly to Vegas and told the story along with the joke,
right?
And I said,
I say to my wife at the airport,
who's more likely to get aids this weekend?
May Are you.
And so,
uh,
so I go there and I'm,
I'm doing my,
you know,
you do like 10,
15 minutes at the beginning and is 5,000 coked up porn stars and they're all,
you know,
they got a camera in the audience and the chicks are showing their tits and you
know,
porn stars,
it's all about them.
And you got to make it all about you.
So it was tough.
And then I got him and I couldn't get Dave Navarro.
He's sitting in the front row and the dude is just like looking down,
he's not making eye contact,
get sunglasses on.
And I start to feel like it's,
you know how it is a comic,
you step one person's not laughing,
it bothers you.
Now,
make it a big celebrity and now make it,
you feel like everybody's looking at him,
looking at you because he's a big star and that's affecting how they're
laughing.
So I go on stern the next week and I start talking about it and I,
I went too far.
I called them a Douche and whatever.
I called him the Mexican prince.
And uh,
and so anyway,
uh,
so then he went on stern and of course stern pulled up the clip and played for
Dave
and Dave.
He called me a cunt.
And then it,
when I was doing Carolla's podcast and I talk shit about,
and it went back and forth,
mostly mostly me.
And then I was a,
I was the head writer on David tells show the Gong show and they used to bring
in celebrity judges.
So Navarro is one of the three celebrity judges.
It's,
it's triumph,
the insult dog comic.
And I forget the other guy,
I,
Andy,
Dick and uh,
Dave Nevara.
And so before the show,
one of my jobs was we had jokes prepared for each of the acts that they were
going to see.
And we would basically put them all up on the board and say,
who wants what?
And they'd read them and they'd pull the index card down.
Like,
all right,
I got this one on the guy on stilts and Andy Dick's.
Got It.
So they're all picking the jokes and then Navarro is there and we're standing
there and he's looking at the jokes and I go,
if there's anything you need,
he goes,
oh.
And I threatened to kick his ass
on the air.
And he goes,
so you still want to kick my ass?
But he said it with this little glint in his eye and we both just started
laughing.
You know,
it's funny,
we just laughed.
And then,
uh,
by the end of the show he gave me his number.
I started texting with him,
he came on my radio show,
my podcast,
and we,
and these come back a bunch of times since.
Great fucking guy.
That's hilarious.
Did you apologize?
Did He,
yeah,
I apologize.
Oh,
that's funny.
I said,
I was out of line.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
you know what the worst part is?
The truth is,
I thought you were fucking hilarious.
I told all my friends about how funny you were.
He goes,
I just,
he goes,
I had had a Gig the night before.
I flew to Vegas.
I did red carpet all day,
and then I was so tired of that thing.
Wow.
Yeah.
I stopped doing that shit.
I used to,
I used to fucking call people out all the time.
I,
it's not worth it anymore.
You're wrong.
Most of the time
it's also a negative.
Yeah.
Ignore them,
but better off ignoring,
I mean,
it's one thing to make fun,
like if Dave Navarro was wearing something really silly,
if he starts wearing dresses,
you know,
which he might,
you could start mocking them.
Nothing wrong with that,
but to just get angry,
fuck that Douche,
like that Kinda,
that's encouraged.
And a lot of radio shows,
like that's a big thing with radio,
like these angry call outs where people just as a,
you know,
ranting and screaming about someone who's not there and shitting all over them
unless they really fucked up,
unless there's something really wrong with them or they did something really
offensive most of the time.
Still worth it.
Yeah.
And I've done it to comics and then you're in a green room at a fucking show,
you know,
like an la show and you just kinda like,
I had an experience with a comic like that.
Yeah.
I just,
um,
I apologize.
Oh,
and then I shit on carrot top one time on Stern,
you know,
when you were young coming,
like when I first started doing stern,
I was still like that,
you know,
that shit on carrot top that makes me edgy.
And so I'm making fun of carrot top.
And then like,
uh,
about a month later I'm at the Improv and I'm waiting at the valet parking for
my car and then he walks out and waiting and,
and I,
I look at him and he looks at me and then I go,
uh,
I go,
hey man,
I'm sorry about what I sat on Stern.
It goes,
and he goes,
hey,
don't worry about it man.
We're comics.
We just fuck around.
It's just jokes.
Totally let me off the hook was so cool that it made me feel even worse.
Apparently his name's Scott something who needs just,
apparently he's just the nicest guy in the world and you get older and you
realize who the fuck am I?
Carrot top is really,
really good at what he does.
Like no one's doing prop shit anymore.
And then I watch them.
It's like,
it's clever.
His audience loves it.
He ain't taken asses out of my seats.
My fans aren't going to see Karen Thomas
was,
who cares?
Cares.
Yeah.
He um,
Hicks used to shit on carrot top.
Of course I saw Hicks do a whole bit where you will start reading off of like,
who's going to be there at the,
uh,
the upcoming like things on the pamphlets that they would move on the desk and
he picks up,
he goes,
oh,
carrot top.
So that's for people to think Gallagher's too.
Heady.
He goes,
I like gallery,
but I don't understand all the references.
Greg Fitzsimmons your principal young man.
It's been a fun podcast.
We just did three hours.
Is that three?
Yup.
Can I give you some dates?
Fuck yeah.
Are you going to give it to the website first?
Oh,
fits dog.com podcast is fits dog radio twice a week.
Twitter,
uh,
Twitter is at Greg Fitz Shell and um,
check it out and also,
um,
got some dates.
Indianapolis,
mortise comedy joint is going to be May 8th
through the 10th place.
How is it?
Good.
Plus I've never done it.
Great.
Set up.
Did you do a Bob and Tom when you were in town?
Yes,
I did.
I love those guys.
Nice guys.
Yeah.
Good.
Laughers.
Uh,
and then I'm going to be coming out to,
um,
fuck.
Where am I at?
Fifth and seventh good nights in Raleigh,
North Carolina.
Seven nights anymore.
It's,
which is good though.
It's good.
It's like a John Cougar Mellencamp and then I'm at Foxwoods in Connecticut on
June 12th through the 14th.
Those are going to be the days of their calling you up to try to give you
emotional support because you're not gonna want to do that too.
Let's a start,
dude.
That's the,
he knows who dark.
That's the darkest of the dark ones.
Yeah.
That's the one you don't want to do.
That's the one.
Calvin called me up the other day and he was there and he explained to me that
the district,
we'll talk to him after the show.
We'll talk.
He's coming in next.
We'll talk to him about Foxwoods.
No disrespect fox woods.
If you're out there.
I did it once.
I've been the fights there too.
I'll leave it at that.
You know,
we're not going to love that.
It'll cheer me up.
Is Addison Texas U Nine Fox 21st that's,
that's a fucking room.
That's a fucking gig around.
Yeah.
Dallas Improv.
And then other dates coming up in Phoenix,
Seattle.
Go to the website.
What's the website again?
There fits dog.com or Greg fitzsimmons.com and also my one hour special life on
stage is on Netflix.
Big,
big,
uh,
positive reviews on there.
I loved it,
man.
I listened to it in my car.
I downloaded
it off of Amazon MP3.
I got it in like three minutes.
I was driving.
I listen to at home.
Coming from the Irvine Improv one night was grateful.
Thanks Greg.
Fitzsimmons thanks to ting for supporting our podcasts.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save 25 bucks off of any of their new and awesome
devices.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the code word Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back in.
It is right now.
We'll be back in about an hour and a half with Brian Cowen and Brendan Schaub.
We're going to do the UFC breakdown from this past weekend's fights.
And,
uh,
this weekend,
Friday night,
the Lobero theater in Santa Barbara is sold out.
Uh,
there might be some tickets available at the door the day of if we release some
of the comps,
but other than that,
go fuck yourselves.
All right.
Uh,
we love you.
Big Kiss and see you soon.
Wow.
Gotcha.